le dessus on va pouvoir commencer notre
notre commission
très important quand on a des
agriculteurs dans sa commission Monsieur
le Directeur
commençons toujours par le point météo
surtout en cette période voilà difficile
mes chers collègues
je suis très heureuse d'accueillir ce
matin Monsieur le Directeur Scientifique
agriculture de l'inrae Monsieur
Christian huygues je vous remercie donc
d'être là ce matin pour évoquer avec
notre commission bien sûr les solutions
scientifiques et techniques que votre
institut de recherche sur mesure
d'apporter à nos 400 000 exploitants
agricoles on le sait les sujets que nous
allons aborder ce matin sont des sujets
qui sont compliqués à la fois compliqué
techniquement scientifiquement mais
aussi compliqué politiquement mais
évidemment passionnant car c'est en eux
que se trouve la clé pour relever le
défi de notre production agricole de
notre souveraineté alimentaire et de la
transition écologique nous allons aller
droit au but Monsieur le Directeur
Scientifique
l'idée de cette audition mais m'est
venue bien sûr parce que régulièrement
nous voyons l'inrae et que ça faisait un
petit moment d'abord que nous l'avions
pas auditionné mais surtout l'idée m'est
venue après la décision de la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne du 23
janvier dernier confirmant que les
dérogations de certains États membres
dont la France était que les dérogations
donc était interdites pour l'usage de
deux néonicotinoïdes
bien connu le
diamétoxane pardon et la Claudia nidina
voilà pour les noms doux de ces produits
dîner cotinoïdes en l'occurrence les
surtranspositions ne sont pas en cause
puisque c'est une décision de justice
fondée sur un règlement de 2009 valable
sur l'ensemble du territoire de l'Union
Européenne mais il n'empêche que ces
décisions des conséquences économiques
souvent difficiles la coopérative
agricole terre et eau ça par exemple
annoncé des projets de fermeture dont
l'une de ces sucreries à escaudoeuvre
dans le Nord puisque la baisse des
volumes de betterave la rend impossible
à rentabiliser d'autres substances
actives sont en sursis le S métola
chlore un des herbicides les plus
utilisés en France dans le maïs le soja
ou le tournesol a fait l'objet d'un avis
de lances défavorable ainsi lieu si
j'ose dire la porte d'entrée très
concrète de cette audition sera la
suivante quelle solution et surtout à
quel horizon pour aider les cultivateurs
à surmonter les interdictions et les
menaces d'interdiction ou en sont les
différents programmes et équipements
prioritaires de recherche quelles sont
les perspectives en matière de sélection
génétique des végétaux je sais que c'est
votre champ de spécialité d'agriculture
de précision de pratiques culturelles
permettant de réduire l'impact des
ravageurs ou de désherber de façon plus
ciblée y a-t-il également des recherches
sur d'éventuelles molécules miroir qui
aurait les mêmes bénéfices que les
substances aujourd'hui utilisées mais
qui serait moins dangereuse pour la
santé et les et l'environnement on a
tendance à oublier que la dangerosité de
chaque molécule est différente et qu'il
ne faut pas mettre probablement tous les
produits phytos dans le même lot plus
généralement la trajectoire proposée par
la Commission européenne de réduction de
50 % l'utilisation des produits phytaux
chimiques d'ici à 2035 s'annonce heurté
car porteuse d'un pastèque technique
pour certaines filières la profession
agricole est évidemment très inquiète de
l'impact du pacte vert sur le potentiel
de production et donc sur notre
souveraineté alimentaire dans l'Union
européenne quelle pourra être la
contribution de l'inrae au ce qu'on
appelle plan d'action stratégique pour
anticiper le retrait des substances
actives potentiellement problématiques
et renforcer le pilotage et l'adaptation
des techniques de production des
cultures je cite donc annoncé par la
première ministre au salon de
l'agriculture
concrètement avez-vous des solutions à
court terme quelle solution globale
l'inrae propose-t-il pour lisser cette
transition les résultats d'une expertise
scientifique collective de l'inrae sur
je cite une Europe sans pesticides
chimique en 2050 ont été présentés le 21
mars il s'appuie sur trois scénarios
dont vous nous parlerez probablement
impliquant les technologies numériques
sélection génétiques les
micro-organismes encore la
diversification des cultures est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner quelques
éclairages et quelques conclusions et
enfin dans quelle mesure les
préoccupations économiques et
environnementales peuvent-elles se
rejoindre peut-on vraiment mener de
front la bataille de la compétitivité de
la souveraineté alimentaire et celle de
la transition écologique c'est bien sûr
notre vœu notre commission a récemment
adopté un rapport sur la compétitivité
de la ferme France messieurs Duplomb
Louhans
et merryou qui appelle notamment l'inrae
consacré davantage à la recherche
appliquée et à renforcer les
collaborations avec les instituts
techniques dans cet esprit nous serions
intéressés de vous entendre de votre
réponse évoquée des exemples peut-être
très concrets très parlant de programmes
de recherche de l'inrae qui ont donné
des résultats concrets dans tous les
domaines et qui bénéficient donc aux
exploitations agricoles voilà Monsieur
le Directeur mon petit propos liminaire
et mes premières questions et je vous
laisse la parole bien sûr pour votre
propos liminaire et probablement les
premières réponses merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs merci
de nous accueillir tout d'abord excuser
Philippe Mauguin donc le Président
Directeur Général d'inrae qui
aurait dû être là mais si la vie être là
on aurait dû repousser beaucoup la date
il rentre d'un déplacement en
Nouvelle-Zélande il avait une
incertitude pour aller en Chine donc
c'était un peu compliqué donc
faute de gris vous devez manger un merle
et donc je vais essayer de
le remplacer
peut-être que vous réponds seront plus
scientifiques
je sais pas vous vous jugerez
et après je prendrai un joker non non
mais plus sérieusement les questions que
vous avez posées madame la Présidente et
que elle rejoignent un sujet absolument
majeur pour pour inrae qui est la
question de comment on assure une
performance économique une performance
productive en réduisant l'impact sur le
milieu le fait de améliorer l'impact sur
le milieu en réduisant la production
c'est facile en fait
ça reviendrait à dire qu'on est sur une
une relation négative presque linéaire
entre l'impact qu'on a sur le milieu et
la production que l'on a et auquel cas
en fait on ne fait aucun progrès donc on
n'est pas du tout nous dans cette
logique là on est à se poser la question
de comment on peut imaginer des systèmes
de production des systèmes qui vont
depuis la production jusqu'à la
consommation j'aime oublier qu'au milieu
il y a un truc qui s'appelle des
industries agroalimentaires qui
permettent de d'assurer une performance
productive une performance économique
répondre à la demande des consommateurs
et plus largement même pour les biens
non alimentaires chez nous en Europe et
jouer notre responsabilité dans le monde
et en même temps
je puis dire réduire l'impact sur
l'environnement c'est améliorer
l'incidence qu'on a sur l'environnement
on peut pas considérer que dire je
réduis l'impact sans l'environnement
c'est satisfaisant parce que quand on
utilise cette phrase on légitime
l'impact environnement et donc il faut
et c'est vraiment là-dedans que qui ne
est engagé travailler à
la fois l'innovation mais en fait en
même temps que l'innovation c'est
réfléchir au trajectoire que les
systèmes de production peuvent peuvent
prendre et pour répondre à cet enjeu et
en même temps travailler à relever les
grands défis environnementaux que nous
avons qui sont le changement climatique
il est
enfin tout le monde en mémoire les
difficultés de l'été 2022 qui n'est
absolument pas une année extrême dans
les scénarios climatiques qu'on pourrait
avoir d'ici 2030 c'est-à-dire demain
matin et je ne parle pas de ce que ça
peut être en 2050 avec effectivement des
températures très élevées 2022 a été
marquée par trois canicules trois
périodes de canicule selon les
définitions actuelles on va devoir
changer les définitions pour ne pas être
tout le temps canicule et puis des
stress hydriques extrêmement marqués et
on commence l'année 2023 avec des
réserves hydriques qui sont très basses
et donc
il est peu vraisemblable qu'ils se
mettent à pleuvoir en continu et que
donc on est une année 2023 qui soit
sereine donc on voit bien qu'on doit
résoudre ce défi du changement
climatique en ayant en ayant à la fois
une adaptation à ses températures qui
monte et aux aléas en particulier de
ressourcydriques et en réduisant nos
émissions gaz à effet de serre donc ça
c'est un énorme bloc l'agriculture elle
est pour 3% du PIB c'est 20% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
France donc on
pourrait y revenir mais vous avez déjà
rencontré mon collègue Thierry kaki qui
vous avez raconté des éléments là-dessus
donc ça c'est une des dimensions l'autre
dimension c'est assurer la restauration
de la biodiversité
et ceci pour deux raisons le premier
c'est que la biodiversité existe et
c'est une forme de bien commun de
l'humanité le deuxième c'est que la
biodiversité elle apporte des services à
l'agriculture on mettrait souvent en
avant le service de la pollinisation un
peu plus de la moitié des espèces que
nous consommons sont issus d'une
pollinisation par les insectes mais il y
a tout plein d'autres services qui sont
assurés par les insectes les services de
régulation
et donc les insectes comme d'autres
comme tous les autres organismes
appartiennent à des chaînes alimentaires
et donc il y a des organismes qui
mangent des insectes parasites qui sont
le bas de la chaîne alimentaire mais
c'est aussi d'autres éléments en
particulier la fertilité du sol qui est
directement liée à l'activité de la
biodiversité dans le sol que ce soit une
diversité biodiversité phonistique comme
les lombrics que tout le monde connaît
mais aussi une diversité microbienne il
y a
par hectare de sol en France en moyenne
alors ça varie d'un lieu à l'autre mais
en moyenne vous avez une virgule 5
tonnes de d'animaux donc en gros de vers
de terre vous avez 5 tonnes de Racine
vous avez 5 tonnes de microbes donc de
bactéries qui jouent un rôle absolument
considérable dans la fertilité et donc
en fait la question que l'on a en
matière agricole c'est comment on arrive
à avoir cette restauration des services
de la biodiversité
on assurant nos fonctions productives et
effectivement les pesticides que vous
avez mentionnées madame le présidente
se retrouve à avoir un impact direct
là-dessus et impact que l'on ne
connaissait pas bien objectivement quand
ils ont été mis sur le marché au début
et puis ensuite on a organisé les
systèmes autour de ça jusqu'à se
retrouvent en situation de tension et je
prendrai l'exemple que vous avez
introduit des fameux néonicotinoïdes
et donc que je connais bien
pas à titre personnel mais parce que
j'ai la chance de présider le comité de
coordination technique du plan national
de recherche innovation sur la betterave
que Monsieur Louault connaît bien aussi
et
effectivement la question de ce plan
c'est comment on arrive à sortir d'une
utilisation d'une dépendance totale à un
insecticide ou un groupe d'insecticides
dépendance totale depuis 1993 puisque
c'est des molécules qui ont été
introduites dans la pharmacopée de
traitement de semences de betteraves en
1993 et qui ont fait 100% du système
et donc effectivement comme vous l'avez
rappelé madame la Présidente par
décision par arrêt de la Cour de justice
de l'Union européenne du 19 janvier
dernier il y a un certain nombre de
molécules utilisées en traitement de
semence vous avez cité la crucianidine
de diametoxam il y a aussi limite à
cloperie qui est dans le même charrette
et puis les profunnels Français c'était
ému du fait que l'arrêt portait
exclusivement sur les les
néonicotinoïdes utilisées en traitement
de semences et l'Union européenne a
précisé que cet arrêt s'appliquait aussi
à ceux qui étaient utilisés en
traitement végétation et en particulier
un d'entre eux qui avaient été utilisé
en régime dérogatoire par l'Allemagne en
2020 qui est l'acétamyride que la France
n'utilise pas
en fait si vous prenez l'exemple de ces
de ces néonicotinoïdes et la trajectoire
nécessaire à la sortie on voit en fait
se dessiner les défis que l'on a pas les
difficultés mais les défis que l'on a
pour à peu près toutes les filières
alors en fait comment pourquoi c'est
néonicotinoïde marcher aussi bien
et avait et pourquoi ils ont eu un tel
impact sur le milieu il marche aussi
bien parce que c'est un groupe de
molécules qui a le même effet que la
nicotine qui cible une
qui ont une cible sur les systèmes
nerveux des insectes et en citant un
récepteur particulier qui est un
récepteur acétylcholine ils vont le
bloquer et la particularité c'est que
cette cible elle est partagée par
absolument tous les insectes donc tous
les insectes sont touchés de la même
façon par ces molécules là et c'est
quelque chose qui était connu je cite
toujours cet exemple là parce que ça
montre la profondeur de l'histoire mais
Jean-Baptiste de La Quintinie en 1680 a
écrit un petit recueil conseillant au
lingère de France de mettre des feuilles
de tabac entre les linges de maison et
les draps de maison pour les protéger
contre les insectes le seul chose qui
n'a pas changé c'est qu'en fait on
s'adresse encore au lingère aujourd'hui
donc la parité n'a pas beaucoup bougé
mais
mais donc ce système là est connu depuis
longtemps et les néodies cotinoïdes sont
une famille assez restreinte il y a que
cette molécules néonicotinoïde qu'un
jour était produite dans le dans le
monde et simplement 5 qui ont été
utilisés un jour en Europe
joue ce mécanisme là et donc touche
absolument tous les insectes et c'est
pour ça alors les insectes présentent
pas tous exactement la même sensibilité
mais ils sont touchés et c'est des
produits qui en plus sont systémiques
c'est à dire vous les appliquez sur une
plante et ils vont circuler dans la
plante vous appliquez sur une graine la
racine au moment où elle va toucher la
cuticule de la graine va pouvoir en
absorber et dans le cas des betteraves
on observe à peu près 25% de ce qui est
mis à disposition donc ça touche tous
les insectes
après tout ça les pollinisateurs pas
forcément grave puisqu'il y a pas de
pollinisateur sur la betterave je
reviendrai après sur cette question là
mais comme vous avez mis il n'y a que
25% qui est prélevé il y en a 75% qui
reste dans le sol et donc tous les
insectes du sol
vont pouvoir être exposés à ça et là une
des grandes surprises qu'on a eu en 2020
année qui a été une forme de révélateur
de ce drame là à conduit à une surprise
c'est qu'il y a certains insectes qui
ont eu un comportement qui n'était pas
normal
et notamment on aurait dû avoir des
carabes qui déboulent en quantité
industrielle pour manger les pucerons
parce que les carats utilisent les
pucerons comme étant le dessert donc
voilà c'est c'est le 2 sevré c'est la
fin de leur régime alimentaire et ils
sont pas venus parce qu'en fait il y
avait pas la base de leur régime
alimentaire qui est de manger des
colombols et les colombols sont des
petites arthropodes qui vit dans les
sols mais qui en fait passe leur temps à
manger des pellicules de de graines
et il les mange et il me donc il y avait
plus de colomboles donc il y a pas la
base du régime alimentaire et donc les
carabes sont allés voir ailleurs le
temps qu'il faisait
alors ça c'est le premier élément et
donc on voit bien que ça touche
largement et que donc il faut qu'on
regarde la totalité de l'écosystème dans
lequel on travaille deuxième élément qui
est important et qui faisait en fait une
des forces de ces molécules et qui en
même temps leur très grande faiblesse
c'est leur demi-vie qui est très longue
la demi-vie d'un produit comme limite
c'est 228 jours et donc ça veut dire
qu'au bout de 228 jours vous avez encore
5 50% de la molécule qui est présente et
donc qui est disponible dans la surface
dans la dans le sol puis au bout de
456 jours vous en avez encore 25%. et en
fait aux quantités apportées à ces
quantités là ces teneur là si 450 jours
après vous semez une plante elle va être
en mesure d'absorber et d'avoir donc ces
molécules là présentes dans ces feuilles
dans ces fleurs dans son hectare et en
fait c'est ça la vraie question ça veut
dire que quand vous avez mis une
betterave pendant deux années vous avez
des quantités de de dimida cloperie par
exemple disponible dans le sol qui sont
encore à des teneurs suffisante pour
avoir un impact sur la biodiversité donc
d'où les dans le cadre de la de la loi
de 2020 il y avait eu cette interdiction
que pendant les deux années après les
betteraves il est utilisation de colza
il y a pire que la
limited que la France n'a jamais utilisé
qui est en fait un produit stable et en
gros c'est le chlore des cône de la
métropole enfin si on heureusement on
l'a pas utilisé donc on a ces incidences
là et donc la question elle est comment
on fait pour sortir de ça et c'est là
que ce qu'on là on peut faire un constat
où on est extrêmement pessimiste mais la
question c'est comment en fait on fait
pour sortir de ça et dans le et c'est ce
que je vais expliquer maintenant en fait
vous pouvez l'utiliser sur à peu près
toutes les substances et toutes les
questions que qui sont posées parce que
on a le même vous avez entendu entendre
parler du plan fausset qui est un autre
un organo phosphoré un peu problématique
et qui de toute façon aujourd'hui
disparu il y a le dimétoade vous avez on
est toujours autour de la même question
avec une difficulté supplémentaire pour
la betterave qui est que en fait on
travaille pas dans le dialogue entre une
betterave et un pucerons on travaille
dans un triangle betterave pucerons
virus le puceron étant là que comme
étant un vecteur et son incidence propre
est assez proche de zéro sauf certaines
années avec des abondances et on est
face à deux pucerons le puceron vert du
péché misus persisté et le
puceron de la féverole à fils fabée qui
a un puceron noir qui est pas le pire
que l'on est il a tendance à faire des
colonies assez denses mais il est pas il
est pas le plus problématique le plus
problématique est misus persisté et donc
le cycle dans lequel on est c'est que on
a une betterave qui est sensible
à
au virus
et dont on sait pas trop si elle a un
effet quel est son effet quelle est sa
relation avec un puceron le puceron
arrive les pucerons et les arrivent et
ils arrivent tous exactement du même
endroit ils sont issus de colonies qui
se développent sur le colza et donc le
colza les colza d'hiver que l'on a tous
les colza que l'on est en France l'école
d'hiver ils héberge des colonies de
misus persistaient qui leur font ni
chaud ni froid c'est voilà c'est
colonies en fait elles sont en place
durant l'hiver et au fait au printemps
avec la température qui monte les
colonies augmentent en taille et quand
une colonie atteint une certaine taille
et ben en fait les insectes ont
subissent une mutation une modification
morphologique il y a une génération qui
acquiert des ailes et donc qu'il y ait
les ailes ils s'en vont et en fait en
allant du colza où ils sont tout propres
ils ont ils portent pas de virus jusqu'à
la betterave sucrière il s'arrête à
certains endroits pour piquer et en fait
une seule piqûre leur permet de
collecter des virus
et donc on a dans le cadre du plan
que je mentionnais et que Monsieur
nouveau connaît bien on a géré ces
différentes dimensions et donc d'abord
pour la betterave c'est comment on fait
pour la rendre résistance assez virus
sachant qu'on n'a pas un virus on en a
quatre
un qui est pas trop problématique le
virus de la mosaïque mais trois qui sont
assez problématiques des virus de la
jaunisse dont le by V qui est le pire
donc on doit apporter des résistances à
au moins ces trois premiers virus donc
de polyrovirus et le pays
donc ça ce bloc là il est dans les mains
des sélectionneurs on sait que ça va
prendre un certain temps mais ils sont
tous dans ce chemin là et
si on aura et on aura des variétés
résistantes il va falloir aussi les
protéger parce que si on met des
variétés résistantes avec une pression
maximale de virus les virus vont faire
le tour on est tous habitués maintenant
à avoir des variantes sur des virus on
connaît tous l'histoire du coronavirus
des variants qui apparaissent mais si
vous mettez une variété résistante elle
est résistante à une souche et si vous
maximisez la pression et ben en fait
vous allez sélectionner des souches qui
vont contourner donc on doit faire des
variétés résistantes et on doit les
protéger ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point c'est comment on les
protège on les protège en réduisant les
populations de pucerons et donc c'est un
vrai secteur de travail et donc ce que
l'on fait là dessus c'est d'abord
modéliser pourquoi les pucerons ils
arrivent je vous disais ils viennent du
colza
ils vont s'arrêter quelque part pour
s'alimenter ils arrivent sur la
betterave qu'est-ce qu'il détermine
leurs dates d'arrivée c'est en fait
c'est une phénologie c'est totalement
déterminé par les les sommes de
température en particulier comme c'est
on est sur des courbes exponentielles en
fait il faut comprendre le début de la
courbe exponentielle qui est la fête la
température moyenne du 1er janvier au 15
février et en fait ça permet de prédire
la date d'arrivée moyenne donc je peux
vous prédire que la date moyenne
d'arrivée sur l'ensemble de la seule
betteravière française en 2023 sera le 2
mai pas le 1er mai parce qu'ils font le
pont mais le 2 mai et en fait avec des
variations plus une arrivée on retrouve
avec une par rapport à ces dernières
années on retrouve une distribution de
dates qui a qui est assez cohérente en
fait plutôt dans le sud-ouest de la zone
et la bordure côtière qui est qui est
plus précoce et puis plus vous allez
vers le nord-est plus la date d'arrivée
la date d'arrivée sera tardive donc on a
un mécanisme qu'on connaît ce qui fait
que de ce point de vue là pour
ceux qui sont qui ont des betteraves
dans dans les zones que que vous êtes
donc vous êtes les représentants cette
année la mauvaise nouvelle c'est les
dates de SMIC qui sont très tardives en
fait parce que on avait encore en début
de semaine que 50% des betteraves qui
étaient semaient ce qui est pas la bonne
nouvelle bref donc il faut on a modélisé
et ensuite il faut faire en sorte que
par rapport à ce modèle c'est comment on
fait pour les ralentir et en fait on a
trois leviers pour les ralentir qu'on
utilise en fonction de la date d'arrivée
c'est la date d'arrivée très précoce il
faut mettre des plantes campagnes qui
jouent en fait comme un effet répulsif
il y a une plante campagne qui
fonctionne bien qui est la voie de Rude
qui a comme particularité de modifier et
le paysage olfactif et le paysage visuel
et donc sur le premier les 6 premières
semaines d'installation de la betterave
jusqu'au stade 4 feuilles elles vont
assurer cette protection si par contre
la prévision est suffisamment tardive
pour qu'il y ait rien jusqu'au stade 4
feuilles mais c'est pas la peine de les
mettre deuxième levier qui va être
totalement validé cette année parce
qu'il a une incertitude sur l'échelle
spatiale on utiliser c'est des produits
répulsifs des keromones les insectes
sont sensibles qu'à deux types d'odeurs
les odeurs pour leur reproduction donc
c'est des phéromones sexuels qu'on
utilise quand on fait de la confusion
sexuelle par exemple sur le pommier ou
sur ou sur la tordeuse de la grappe
envie en viticulture et ça c'est leur
premier groupe de composés auxquels ils
sont sensibles et l'autre composé notre
groupe de composés c'est en fait les
endroits où ils vont s'alimenter donc
certains sont
exclusivement attirés par une odeur et
donc ils vont s'alimenter sur une seule
cible d'autres sont plutôt repoussés par
un cocktail et dans le cas du puceron
effectivement il y a un cocktail qui est
le mélange de deux molécules dans un
ratio très particulier qui en fait a
tendance à dire aux insectes aux
pucerons d'aller voir ailleurs puis
troisième levier plus on va se
rapprocher en fait de la date de fin de
couverture qu'on va obtenir qui en gros
le début du mois de juin à ce moment-là
il faut utiliser les insectes ici de
contact on a le droit à un flux
nickamide donc le tpki qui est homologué
avec une application et donc avec ces
trois leviers là en fait on arrive à
repousser la date d'arrivée des pucerons
et en fait s'ils viennent ils viennent
avec des populations très basses donc ça
c'est le deuxième composant et le
troisième composant c'est en fait jouer
chose qu'on avait très peu dans le début
du PNL le souvenez-vous monsieur lourd
c'est comment on fait pour jouer sur le
réservoir viral parce que en fait on
savait pas trop où c'est pucerons aller
chercher leur virus pour ça qu'on avait
au départ fait beaucoup de recherches
sur les adventices en disant il doit
avoir des mauvaises herbes quelque part
qui joue un rôle bizarre en fait non les
réservoir viral c'est les autres
betteraves et donc en fait il y a deux
réservoirs viraux c'est les betteraves
portes graines dans le sud du Bassin
parisien il y a 800 hectares de
betteraves porte graines qui sont semés
au mois d'août récolter au mois de
juillet l'année suivante et qui font une
forme de pont mais c'est cuisson
hectares et surtout et c'est là le
composé le volume principal c'est toutes
les repousses de betteraves quand vous
récoltez une parcelle de betteraves sur
les en gros 80 90 tonn le racisme
disponible il y a une tonne qui n'est
pas récolté les petites qui restent à la
surface du sol puis vous avez vous les
mettez en silo ce qui a été récolté vous
les avant de partir à l'usine elles sont
déterrées donc ça fait ce qu'on appelle
des cordons des terrasses les cordons il
y a des bouts de betterave dedans qui
peuvent repousser mais surtout le gros
du paquet c'est les repousses de
betteraves alors vous allez dire bah oui
mais elles vont être enfouis ben non
parce qu'il y a 50% des blés derrière
betterave qui sont en semis direct et
donc les petites betteraves restent à la
surface et donc en fait il faut intégrer
cette question là pour que on gère
différemment c'est c'est Lola et donc on
arrive à faire s'effondrer le le
réservoir viral et ce qui fait que les
pucerons s'ils arrivent ils seront
propres et auquel cas ils feront rien et
en fait ce que vous voyez derrière ça
excusez-moi je suis un peu long mais
c'est pour essayer de de vous expliquer
les choses et d'essayer de me faire
comprendre des fois c'est un peu
compliqué je me mélange un peu les
pinceaux mais
ce que vous voyez derrière ça c'est que
on doit jouer à la fois sur
N9 vient en même temps
que pour l'agriculteur il va y avoir une
forme de complexité on va remplacer un
solvier avant qui était qui était même
plus un levier vous achetiez des
semences un agriculteur acheter des
semences elles étaient enrobées en fait
qu'elles sont enrobées avec du bleu du
jaune du rouge c'est ça change rien et
là on va lui dire bah oui mais il faut
que tu choisisses la variété il faut que
tu utilises le modèle d'arrivée de des
pucerons pour savoir si tu vas devoir
mettre des plans de campagne utiliser un
répulsif ou simplement un TP qui suffira
et puis tu vas devoir toi et tes voisins
gérer
le réservoir viral et peut-être que
l'année prochaine en plus on va
t'expliquer que ça serait bien que tu
préoccupes aussi de tes colza pour que
il ne sert pas de réservoir de puce
mais donc on peut prendre de côté très
négatif de ça mais le côté très positif
de ça en fait c'est que les agriculteurs
d'abord ils savent faire quand ceux qui
veulent s'attaquer à cette question là
et il y en a qui le font ils peuvent
faire ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que en faisant ça
on va permettre de la restauration de
régulation biologique parce qu'en fait
la particularité quand vous mettez un
insecticide mais comme quand vous mettez
un fongicide je vais regarder les
insecticides c'est qu'en fait une
population d'insectes vous la mettez
brutalement à zéro et donc tout le
cortège de régulation et ben il meurt
aussi faute d'alimentation en fait avec
les différents leviers que je viens de
mentionner sur les pucerons en fait vous
ne mettez jamais la population à zéro
elle est à un niveau qu'elle ne génère
pas de dégâts et ça veut dire que
l'ensemble du cortège de régulation
reste présent et les cortèges de
régulation là ils sont ils agissent sur
absolument tous les pucerons ils sont
pas inféodés au puceron vert qui va se
la betterave c'est le même qui va qui va
gérer le puceron la Niger sur le pommier
c'est les mêmes cortèges qui vont gérer
les pucerons sur les céréales qui
potentiellement sont là aussi
vectorisent de la jaunissement de l'orge
voilà vous avez tout un ensemble là qui
qui fait ce que je disais tout à l'heure
comment on fait en préservant la
biodiversité on récupère un certain
nombre de services et donc
c'est un vrai changement d'attitude et
ce qu'il faut en fait en même temps que
toutes ces innovations là on assure on
fasse une innovation organisationnelle
qui permette d'assurer financièrement le
risque qui est pris par un agriculteur
si une année se met je veux pas dire à
dijoncter mais vous tombez sur des
conditions climatiques qui sont juste
extrêmes et qui permettent pas assez
levier là de fonctionner de la même
façon qu'on a des assurances pour une
voiture ou si votre voiture est en bon
état vous avez votre permis et que vous
étiez en état de conduire
vous êtes assuré si un problème et il
faut faire la même chose et donc dans le
cadre du pnli il y a des projets autour
de sa sueur et donc ce que l'on voit en
fait en matière de de façon de
travailler
c'est que
on doit à la fois
être vraiment innovant sur les leviers
faut pas dire qu'en fait on a toutes les
solutions déjà en main c'est pas vrai il
y en a que l'on a et il y en a que l'on
n'a pas et qu'on doit créer donc en même
temps qu'il y a une réflexion sur le
retrait de molécule il faut une vraie
stratégie sur l'innovation ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
que les innovations elles sont d'ordre
biotechnique elles sont d'ordre
organisationnel et je crois moi vraiment
beaucoup à ces innovations de type
organisationnel on a la chance en France
d'avoir des filières qui fonctionnent
bien des interprofessions solides et
donc c'est comment on les utilise pour
avoir ces innovations organisationnelles
innovation aussi dans les territoires
parce qu'en fait il y a certains leviers
que vous ne pouvez pas gérer dans une
logique filière je disais tout à l'heure
vous devez organiser la coexistence par
la coexistence l'articulation entre du
colza et des betteraves ces deux
interprofessions différentes donc comme
vous devez le gérer à l'échelle d'un
territoire et ça relève de logique de
coopération entre agriculteurs et puis à
un certain moment il faudra il faut
faire des formes d'innovation
réglementaires c'est-à-dire comment on
arrive à avoir dans le cadre des
politiques publiques dont vous êtes les
acteurs extrêmement importants comment
ces différentes politiques publiques
sont assure une cohérence à l'histoire
et c'est ces éléments là qu'il faut
qu'il faut faire et donc
comment on
contribue complètement dans dans ces
à l'ensemble de cette activité là à
travers les trois missions de l'Institut
inrae donc organise de recherche donc de
production de connaissances et donc
c'est notre mission première de produire
de la connaissance y compris au travers
de relations internationales j'y
reviendrai dans une minute c'est de
faire une contribution à l'innovation et
toutes nos contributions à l'innovation
se font en partenariat avec soit des
organismes de recherche appliqués comme
les instituts techniques agricoles soit
avec des entreprises et on fait dans le
cadre de levier qui nous intéresse ici
euh dans le cas du biocontrôle par
exemple on a créé un consortium
biocontrôle qui rassemble des organismes
de recherche
Israël mais aussi beaucoup d’universités
qui ont des programmes là-dessus mais
aussi des instituts techniques mais
aussi les entreprises du secteur on fait
la même chose par exemple en ce moment
sur les agro-équipements c'est un gros
équipement sont un levier d'innovation
on y reviendra dans une minute et puis
c'est notre mission d'apiopolitique
publique on est là on a la particularité
d'être le seul organisme de recherche
publique en France et le seul à
l'échelle mondiale de recherche en dans
le domaine de l'agriculture de
l'environnement et de l'alimentation à
avoir dans ses missions
institutionnelles un apio politique
publique qui est à la fois de faire des
études excentées les
exercices de prospective que vous
mentionnez et sur lequel je vais revenir
dans une minute peut-être en deux et
puis aussi par exemple des mises en
oeuvre de politiques publiques on gère
pour le compte de l'État le dispositif
des certificats d'économie de produits
phytopharmaceutiques qui est un levier
mis en place dans le cadre des cophytos
et qui pour accompagner cette transition
les vendeurs de produits ayant des
obligations il faut quantifier les faits
de tel et tel pratiques et en fait en
quantifiant on fait deux choses on donne
une métrique pour pour les obliger mais
c'est surtout en fait on sert de tiers
de confiance aux opérateurs pour dire
mais cette technique là elle fonctionne
parce qu'on lui a donné telle valeur
d'économie qui est très importante par
contre celle là
ça va mais pas beaucoup quoi voilà et
donc cette mission là on l'a et donc on
fait c'est trois choses alors je reviens
sur les la question des différents
programmes qui sont des programmes de
recherche qui sont mis en oeuvre dans ce
dans ce ensemble de cette logique là on
dans le cadre de la de la stratégie
d'accélération agriculture qui s'appelle
sadea et donc qui est la
transformation de l'agriculture dans une
logique d'agroécologie et de performance
productive et économique on a trois PEP
R ou PPR donc programme prioritaire de
recherche ou programme et équipements
prioritaire de recherche le premier donc
qui était quasiment la version 0 de ces
modalités là c'est le PPR cultivé
protégé autrement autour de la logique
de sortie des produits phytosanitaires
où on fait comme l'objectif est de
pousser la recherche à explorer des
fronts nouveaux on a mis un scénario à
zéro pesticides alors c'est pas du tout
un scénario prescriptif je reviendrai
sur ces questions de scénario
prescriptif tout à l'heure c'est pas un
scénario prescriptif c'est en fait un
cadre qui oblige la recherche à explorer
des inconnus et en fait en faisant ça on
a 10 projets absolument majeurs évalué
par un comité scientifique international
il y avait zéro français dans la dans la
commission qui ont regardé tous ces
projets là ils ont sélectionné 10 qui en
fait sont des projets soit à l'échelle
d'une filière soit à l'échelle de levier
d'épidémieusesurveillance de microbiote
et même d'économie qui disent ben voilà
pour contribuer réellement à des
ruptures dans le domaine de la
protection des cultures il faut faire
telle et telle chose et par exemple on a
deux énormes projets sur le microbiote
des végétaux un sur le microbiote des
plantes en croissance et un sur le
microbiote des semences pour comprendre
ce qu'il y a dans ce que fait ce
microbiote
comment il protège la plante comment
potentiellement par moment il peut se
déformer et devenir pathogène on a des
projets absolument majeurs un projet
absolument majeur qu'on utilise dans un
cadre d'épidémie au surveillance pour
prévoir l'arrivée des insectes
uniquement en monitorant leur les
phéromones qui les émettent et donc on
s'est un dispositif
qui est aujourd'hui pratiquement
totalement couvert par des secrets ce
qu'on va essayer de breveter des
logiques vraiment de rupture là-dessus
mais on ayant la capacité avec des
technologies absolument remarquables en
fait à capturer chacune des chaque
molécule unique de phéromones émises par
des insectes et comme elles sont
incroyablement précises vous pouvez
identifier une espèce exclusivement une
seule espèce en comptant les phéromones
qui passent et en couple en ça avec des
modèles aériens vous pouvez nous pouvons
identifier à quel endroit retrouve les
sources des insectes et quelle est la
taille de la population et dans un
dispositif d'épidémieusesurveillance ça
devient en fait un levier majeur à la
fois sur des insectes courants où vous
pouvez prévoir l'arrivée et les vagues
d'arrivée ou alors sur des insectes dont
on craint le fait qu'il ne deviennent
des insectes exotiques qui viennent
s'installer et ben en fait il faut
pouvoir se prémunir et pour se prémunir
il faut pouvoir anticiper leur arrivée
et vaut mieux percevoir leur les
phéromones qu'ils émettent plutôt que de
voir l'insecte voilà et donc c'est parce
qu'on a posé cette question du Zéro
qu'en fait on a forcé les équipes à
aller chercher très loin donc ça c'est
le PPR cultivé protégé autrement le
deuxième grand projet que l'on a c'est
agroécologie et numérique comment la
transition numérique on la met à
disposition de l'agroécologie et le
numérique en fait il y en a dans tous
les coins que ce soit du numérique
basé sur toutes les problématiques
moléculaires qui génèrent énormément de
données c'est le numérique agricole
qu'on utilise destination de robots et
on a des projets sur la robotique c'est
des logiques de reconnaissance vous avez
peut-être dans votre smartphone plante
net et bien plantnet va avoir une
évolution de dans le cas de ce PEPR pour
que ça devienne un instrument de
reconnaissance de maladie ce qui ne peut
pas faire enfin ce que le plante net
actuellement ne fait pas voilà donc on a
du numérique partout et en ayant en
étant extrêmement attentif sur la façon
dont ces données sont gérées et ce
qu'elle permet de faire donc ça c'est le
deuxième P EPM et le troisième PEP r il
s'appelle sélection végétale avancée
pour ne pas dire édition du génome parce
qu'en fait c'est de d'édition des
génomes dont il sera question c'est
comment sur cette technologie qui est
une technologie de rupture comment on
fait on peut en avoir la maîtrise créer
les technologies de demain prendre en
compte les questions de propriété
intellectuelle qui sont embarquées dans
ces sujets là et puis aussi l'appliquer
non pas l'échelle d'une culture mais à
l'échelle de système de sûr en cohérence
avec ce que je vous ai dit avant les
problèmes doivent se réfléchir à
l'échelle des systèmes de culture et on
aura deux flaques enfin deux projets
ciblés emblématiques sur des systèmes de
culture annuelle et un sur production
fruitière et légumière en disant mais si
je veux améliorer et la tolérance
vis-à-vis des aléas climatiques et donc
de l'adaptation changement climatique et
les questions de protection des cultures
dans un système de culture qu'est-ce que
je dois d'abord modifier on n'est pas
obligé de prendre tous les caractères
sur toutes les espèces il faut faire des
priorités donc ça c'est deux
trois PEPR et on a à côté de ça deux
grands défis qui sont totalement eux
ciblés aux partenariat public privé 1 et
sur la robotique agricole
il sera lancé normalement par le
ministre le mois de mai
dans sur un site que nous avons dans
l'Allier et donc il est porté par nous
et par une association de de
constructeurs qui s'appelle robagerie et
donc dans l'objectif est en fait
d'accélérer l'ensemble des
développements sur sur ce sujet là et
l'autre il est autour de biocontrôle et
biostimulant
et donc comment on arrive en fait à
passer d'une logique aujourd'hui ou en
fait c'est un peu excusez-moi
l'expression mais un peu chasseur
cueilleur c'est à dire les laboratoires
mettent en avant tel molécule et on
essaie d'en faire une activité donc il
faut inverser cette logique là en ayant
en fait un criblage à très haut débit de
toutes les possibilités et une analyse à
très haut débit des conditions qui
permettent de maximiser le potentiel de
ces leviers alors qu'aujourd'hui si vous
avez un produit bio contrôle vous
commencez à le tester dans les mêmes
configurations que les produits que les
produits chimiques et ça ça marche pas
parce que la vertu d'un d'un biocide
enfin d'un produit chimique pesticide
c'est de tuer et donc vous supprimez le
problème on le tuant alors que le
biocontrôle il est il a comme approche
de réguler une population et en fait si
vous donc quand vous testez un fongicide
par exemple vous allez obligatoirement
fongicide chimique vous allez le tester
sur la variété la plus sensible alors
que si vous faites un produit de
biocontrôle
vous allez le tester sur la variété la
plus résistante puisque en fait c'est
l'articulation entre les deux qui doit
stabiliser le résultat et en fait ça
c'est des ruptures qu'il faut qu'il faut
embarquer et donc on ça me permet de
répondre à votre à votre série de
questions dans la présidence sur les
perspectives de sélection elles sont
extrêmement importantes les news
technologies venant s'ajouter à
l'ensemble des techniques déjà
disponibles il ne faut jamais oublier
que la première ressource que nous avons
c'est pas de la technologie c'est les
ressources phytogénétiques que nous
avons qui en fait sont des réservoirs de
solutions des formes d'assurance contre
les aléas qu'on peut avoir demain aller
à de pression parasitaire mais aussi à
Léa climatique puisque c'est dans les
ressources phytogénétiques il va falloir
d'abord aller chercher la solution et le
les NBT s'ajouteront dans la panoplie
des leviers et donc sur la résistance
aux maladies on en a et au bio agresseur
on en a beaucoup
en particulier sur les champignons les
virus et les insectes là où les
perspectives de sélection sont très
faibles c'est faire des variétés qui
deviennent qui supportent la présence
d'adventices c'est pas ça levier
principal
sur la question des
donc les leviers aussi contre insectes
et
champignons les leviers du biocontrôle
sont montres des perspectives
extrêmement intéressantes et qui sont
pour parties alimentées par la
découverte de que j'ai déjà mentionnées
du microbiote des végétaux et donc
comment en fait on arrive à réfléchir le
fait que la vision que l'on a tous d'une
plante d'une plante saine c'est une
plante sur lequel il y a rien et en fait
c'est cette vision là qu'il faut c'est
une plante qui est saine c'est une
plante qui est habité
pas spirituellement mais qui est juste
couverte d'un microfilm voilà qui est
couverte d'un microfilm et c'est la
stabilité de ce microfilm là qui assure
la santé de la plante
et qu'en fait une maladie fongique à ce
moment-là c'est une déformation de ce
microbiote mais en fait vous pouvez
faire exactement le parallèle avec le
microbiote humain c'est la même histoire
qui est derrière ça et en fait il y a
une grande partie il peut y avoir des
aléas parce qu'à un moment donné il y a
une pression il y a un champignon qui
arrive de l'extérieur et qui met une
pression énorme sur le microbiote mais
vous pouvez aussi avoir par les
pratiques agricoles des déformations de
ce microbiote et donc par exemple les
usages de fongicides à type préventif en
fait ont une vertu négative en fait ce
qui déstabilise tout un cortège et ça
c'est quelque chose d'assez compliqué ça
pose aussi en passant une forme de défi
réglementaire parce que si vous voulez
apporter un microbiote c'est une
communauté et en fait on regarde de la
réglementation européenne et en
particulier du règlement 1107 2009 une
souche de champignons est un produit
chimique et donc vous n'avez le droit
dans commercialiser que une à la fois et
donc vous pouvez pas vendre une
communauté parce que par construction
une communauté elle est pas descriptible
à un instant donné elle est elle va
bouger au cours du temps et donc la
réglementation aujourd'hui elle ne
permet pas ça et là vous pourriez dire
bah après tout ailleurs c'est plus
permissif que chez nous bah non aux
États-Unis vous avez pas le droit non
plus parce que c'est la même
configuration la même le même cadre
d'analyse préalable qui est que en gros
c'est la chimie qui définit la façon de
faire et donc les molécules qui
définissent la fin de compte donc ça
c'est un grand progrès et l'autre grand
progrès dans le c'est celui des insectes
et c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
l'écologie chimique pourquoi les
insectes se déplacent et donc comment on
peut modifier ce paysage on a aussi des
travaux
que nous nous faisons sur lequel nous
avons énormément d'investissements
c'est la problématique de la
diversification des cultures
tous les travaux que qui sont faits chez
nous et dans le monde montrent que quand
à l'échelle d'un paysage agricole à
l'échelle d'une exploitation agricole à
l'échelle d'une parcelle agricole vous
augmentez la diversité
soit dans le temps soit dans l'espace
soi-même simultanément c'est-à-dire vous
mélangez plusieurs espèces et ben en
fait vous récupérez des tas de services
environnementaux il y a deux excellentes
synthèses qui ont été faites une par
tamburuni publiée en 2020 et une par
bellouin publiée en 2021 qui synthétise
mais loin c'est un peu plus de 1000
papiers tambourini un peu plus de 6000
papiers
élémentaires et qui montre que
à l'exception de deux cas où il y a des
effets négatifs pour les autres soit
vous avez une forme de neutralité dès
que vous diversifiez les espèces mais
aussi les pratiques soit vous avez dans
plus de 75% des situations un bénéfice
bénéfice sur la production bénéfices sur
la régulation des des biogresseurs mais
aussi bénéfices et c'est comme ça en
fait que les travaux de tambourini
avaient commencé sur la fertilité des
sols il y a pas une seule configuration
dans toutes des études qui ont été
faites ou en augmentant la diversité
vous avez un effet négatif sur la
fertilité donc vous allez dire pourquoi
on s'en passe dans son passe parce qu'à
un moment donné on n'a pas eu besoin et
donc on n'a pas regarder et donc cette
logique de diversité elle est
extrêmement importante par contre elle
pose une question qui est absolument
majeure et qui rejoint votre
interrogation sur la sur la
compétitivité c'est que si vous
diversifiez encore faut-il que quelqu'un
consomme et donc la vraie question que
l'on a derrière ça c'est en fait comment
on arrive à analyser simultanément
l'évolution de la production et
l'évolution de la consommation et donc
les trajectoires alimentaires elles font
partie des éléments importants qui
relèvent à la fois des choix mais qui
relèvent aussi de l'éducation et qui
relève de l'offre et donc
et donc au milieu de ça vous avez
l'outil industriel et donc vous avez des
configurations dans les travaux que l'on
mène alors excusez-moi je fais une
petite digression par rapport à la
question de que vous aviez initialement
mais on met en place des travaux via des
démarches originales qui s'appelle des
territoires d'innovation donc ils sont
des démarches où on a à la fois la
recherche des utilisateurs mais aussi
les citoyens et les consommateurs et il
y a un de ces territoires d'innovation
qui est Dijon alimentation durable
peut-être l'un d'entre vous est de la
région dijonnaise et
voilà et donc en fait entre bon la
recherche qui est toujours là mais
disons céréales qui a fournisseur la
métropole de Dijon qui est quand même
ceux qui sont qui sont à l'initiative et
qui portent cette question là avec
l'élément majeur qui est la cantine
centrale qui fait un énorme travail il y
a Seb qui fournit des éléments pour des
éléments techniques en fait pour assurer
les transformations il y a une
transition sur l'offre alimentaire
avec plus de produits végétaux et en
particulier de légumineuses à graines
une diversification de l'offre
alimentaire et la motivation première de
la métropole Dijon n'était absolument
pas mes problèmes nautiques de
pesticides et diversification c'était
comment je réduis l'obésité parmi les
populations d'enfants les plus
défavorisées et des travaux qui ont été
faits à l'échelle européenne montrent
que quand vous augmentez la diversité de
l'offre alimentaire vous réduisez
mécaniquement l'obésité et donc ce
travail là il est porté il donne des
résultats absolument fascinants avec en
fait tout le monde disait oui mais des
légumes à graines les enfants vont
jamais en manger en fait c'est tout à
fait faux les enfants ont au contraire
en fait ont plutôt une appétence pour
très forte pour ce genre de produit
parce qu'ils sont bien cuisinés c'est
plus des lentilles que moi je mangeais à
la cantine et et donc il y a une vraie
innovation là et comme vous le disiez
c'est très bon surtout quand elles sont
très bien cuisinée
voilà et non non mais quand c'est voilà
et c'est ça montre c'est ce que vous
disiez madame la Présidente en fait à la
fois une évolution de l'offre une
évolution de la consommation et de
l'innovation dans les process au milieu
[Musique]
donc je excusez-moi j'ai un peu dérivé
mais parce que cette question de
diversification est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important et elle est
centrale à tout ce que l'on peut faire
demain on a parlé de j'ai mentionné
alors très rapidement la question des
agro-équipements les agrments c'est un
secteur
qui ne rend ne couvrait pas kirsta
couvre un peu et que dans le cadre
d'inrae on a décidé de renforcer et donc
dans la la plateforme il y avait une
unité expérimentale à mon toldre dans
l'Allier on a on fait des
investissements extrêmement important
là-bas pour renforcer notre activité sur
les agro-équipements et sur les
agro-équipements nécessaires à la
transition agroécologique on le fait en
lien avec des entreprises c'est à dire
c'est porter conjointement le comité
d'orientation stratégique à un président
inrae et un vice-président qui est
d'entreprise
et l'objectif en fait n'est pas de faire
les agro-équipements pour aujourd'hui
mais c'est de faire les agro-équipements
pour demain et donc on le fait en fait
au travers de bancs de bancs de
recherche et d'expérimentation en disant
pour assurer tel service de qualité dans
une situation agroécologique de quel
type de machine j'ai besoin et comment
je produis les connaissances et comment
je teste des machines et donc ça permet
d'avoir des entreprises qui sont
présentes donc on fait tout ça il y a un
sujet qu'on fait pas et ça répondra une
de vos questions Adam la présidente
est-ce qu'on travaille sur les molécules
miroir la réponse elle est non on
travaille pas
à la production de molécules chimiques
de demain
alors vous allez dire pourquoi on fait
pas ça pour une raison assez simple
d'abord historiquement le faisait pas
parce qu'il y avait des entreprises qui
le faisaient et le deuxième raison est
c'est la motivation pour aujourd'hui
elle est double c'est que
par rapport à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure même si vous avez une molécule
qui a moins d'impact
toxicologique et côte toxicologique
génotoxygologique elle est quand même à
faire tomber à zéro une population et
donc en fait elle casse les régulations
de logique donc en fait elle est
antinomique de la philosophie et même du
faim c'est pas une philosophie c'est des
mécanismes que l'on cherche à mobiliser
et dont il a été montré qu'ils étaient
extrêmement efficace tout ce qui est
caché derrière le mot transition
agroécologique donc on fait pas ça le
deuxième la deuxième raison et qui pour
moi est en fait une des motivations
majeures de la réflexion sur les ce
qu'on appelle les alternatives aux
pesticides c'est que quand vous regardez
les modes d'action des produits
phytosanitaires
et donc pour toucher des herbices enfin
des mauvaises herbes des champignons ou
des insectes et ben en fait il y a très
peu de mode d'action disponibles le
dernier mode d'action que l'on a
découvert en matière de protection des
cultures est-ce que vous savez de quand
il date
ça fait un certain temps c'est 1994
malheureusement mais moi aussi non mais
ça veut dire qu'en fait en l'espace de
30 ans la recherche est Dieu sait qui en
a en particulier dans des très grosses
entreprises si vous regardez le budget
recherche de Bayer il est juste
considérable par il est 4 fois le budget
eux uniquement le budget recherche donc
et enfin on en trouve pas c'est parce
qu'en fait il y a plus de cible
disponible et en fait cette question là
il faudra vraiment l'avoir présenter en
plus celui qu'on a découvert en 1994 il
a eu une espérance de vie de 5 ans et
donc après il a disparu c'était un
herbicide qui a été totalement
inefficace et en fait comme il n'y a pas
de nouveau mode d'action qui
apparaissent ça veut dire qu'en fait les
l'ensemble de la panoplie que l'on a
aujourd'hui est amené à s'éteindre parce
que les modes d'action quand vous les
utilisez au bout d'un certain temps la
cible finit par contourner le vivant il
est ainsi fait que vous lui mettez une
pression et ben en fait il s'adapte il
fait le tour et donc les modes de
on le voit très bien sur les par exemple
les gestion des des herbicides
pratiquement tous les herbicides à
l'exception de 1 ont vu apparaître des
résistances et pourtant certains comme
le glyphosate par exemple avait un
mécanisme d'action extrêmement
dont on imaginait pas qu'il puisse un
jour être contenté le végétal le fait
mais en fait c'est juste vous faites
vous testez une expérience quelques
milliards de fois et ça finit par
fonctionner c'est la richesse de la
variation naturelle d'où ce que j'étais
alors sur le fait de préserver les
variations naturelles que l'on a dans
disposition donc on fait pas ça et donc
comme on n'a pas de découverte de
système nouveau
et qui a apparition de résistance et ben
en fait cette voie là elle est elle on
l'aura utilisé un certain temps on doit
maîtriser ses impacts et de toute façon
il faut chercher autre chose voilà donc
c'est pour ça qu'on travaille pas là
dessus parce que ça serait une recherche
qui n'aurait pas de sens par rapport à
ça
et donc peut-être que je suis un peu
trop long et que vous avez envie de
poser des questions mais
j'ai essayé de
répondre à certains je vais en garder
que deux pour finir
que je vais terminer par ces deux points
là
est-ce que la trajectoire imposée par la
commission elle est elle est jouable ou
pas jouable en fait je pense qu'elle est
extrêmement c'est une forme de défi de
dire on va
réduire de 50 % les produits chimiques
en fait quand vous regardez l'indicateur
qui est proposé à être utilisé en fait
c'est un peu plus souple que ça parce
que en fait ça donne un poids
considérable l'indicateur H1 qui est
utilisé il donne un poids considérable
au cmr1 et au CMR 2 et donc si vous
réduisez déjà cela vous avez fait une
partie du chemin mais bon c'est c'est un
enjeu ambitieux mais
idem pour la réduction de nos gaz à
effet de serre et et atteindre enfin
tendre vers une forme de neutralité
climatique mais est-ce qu'on regarde la
responsabilité qu'on a sur les
générations suivantes et ce qui a une
option B par rapport à cela et donc de
mon produit il n'y a pas d'option B donc
la question elle est pas de retirer des
choses la question elle est comment on
force l'innovation
et c'est cette question là en fait qui
est centrale c'est que comment on arrive
à booster la recherche et donc nous en
fait on prend notre part dans cette
histoire là et on prend notre part à
niveau national comme je l'ai dit mais
on prend notre part à l'échelle
européenne on a on a mis en place une
alliance européenne de recherche sur ces
problématiques phytosanitaires qui
regroupent aujourd'hui 35 organismes de
20 pays différents avec des beaucoup de
projets européens beaucoup de d'actions
de façon à augmenter les communautés en
particulier avoir des jeunes chercheurs
donc ça c'était le point donc moi je
pense que
on ça va dans le bon sens et
effectivement cette question de la
souveraineté elle est elle est
importante mais encore une fois on ne
peut pas considérer que la consommation
allait elle ne bougera jamais la
consommation elle va bouger et puis le
dernier point c'est vous avez terminé en
revenant sur la recommandation 11 qui
était dans votre dans le rapport
sénatorial d'excellentes factures sur la
compétitivité et cette recommandation
qui était de dire comment
peut être plus mobilisé sur la recherche
appliquée alors
en fait on pourrait lire cette
recommandation de différentes façons
donc je vais la lire tel que moi je l'ai
interprété le premier c'est il faut pas
faudrait pas que cette recommandation
soit considérée comme étant un constat
que la recherche appliquée en France ne
fonctionne pas la recherche appliquée
elle est portée par 18 instituts
techniques agricoles aujourd'hui plutôt
organisé par filière dont la
programmation elle est portée par leur
conseil d'administration qui sont
systématiquement présidés par des
agriculteurs sauf pour celui de l'IFCE
et qui donc le monde agricole en
relation avec un conseil scientifique
réfléchi aux trajectoire et donc cette
recherche elle est de qualité les
instituts techniques agricoles font
partie à l'échelle européenne des
organismes appliqués qui ont le plus
l'efficacité productive si on la mesure
par leur production scientifique
technique ou par leur taux de réussite
dans les projets européens qui est qui
fonctionne très bien j'ai eu la chance
de présider pendant 12 ans le comité
d'orientation scientifique et technique
de Lacta qui chapote ses instituts
techniques donc ça fonctionne bien ce
que le ce que nous cherchons à faire
c'est toujours à renforcer le lien que
nous avons entre la recherche
publique dites finalisée comme inrae et
ses instituts et on a énormément de
projets ensemble mais on veut encore
plus renforcer le lien et le lien de
façon structurelle et enfin ça se fait
ça se traduit en particulier par deux
choses qui sont les unités mixtes
technologiques ont fait on a des
chercheurs et des personnalisations
techniques qui sont au même endroit sur
le même projet dans le même pas de temps
et on est dans le cadre de la révision
de la convention que nous avons avec
Lacta donc c'est une annonce avant que
cette semaine en place on va réviser et
étendre nos UMT en fait en leur donnant
une capacité à couvrir plus large mais
surtout à aller
vers plus d'applications sur le terrain
donc ce qu'on appelle des handfarm
experiment pour parler en bon français
et donc le faire dans ce cadre de ces
réseaux là et puis donc renforcer ça et
renforcer le lien entre ce qui se passe
dans ces dispositifs et le transfert aux
agriculteurs
alors ça veut pas dire que là
faut pas mal prendre ce que je viens de
dire c'est surtout pas de dire les
organismes de développement ne font pas
leur boulot mais c'est comment en fait
on arrive à augmenter en vitesse le
transfert par les outils les outils du
numérique c'est une chose pour mettre à
disposition la connaissance c'est
accueillir des gens sur les sites et
puis c'est aussi travailler avec la
formation et donc l'enseignement
agricole l'enseignement supérieur en
imaginant des systèmes de de d'accueil
de
d'ingénieurs mais aussi de personnes en
formation continue au sein de ces
dispositifs là voilà madame la
Présidente j'ai été un peu long j'en
suis conscient mais j'ai essayé de
couvrir assez ce dossier très riche non
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
directeur pour cette première réponse
évidemment un peu longue mais très
intéressante et on vous remercie de ce
panorama alors mes chers collègues vous
êtes extrêmement nombreux à vous êtes
inscrit pour des questions pour être
clair à ce moment vous êtes 19 donc
c'est très long je vais vous demander
comme il y a quelques années de vous
restreindre chacun à deux minutes par
question maximum ce qui déjà nous
emporte un peu loin première
intervention celle de Daniel Laurent
puis ensuite de pierre-louot oui madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Directeur nous
avions eu le plaisir de vous accueillir
au sein du groupe vignié 20 et nous
avions longuement échangé sur les
recherches agronomiques permettant à la
viticulture de s'adapter aux changements
climatiques et aux attentes de nos
concitoyens
aujourd'hui pour nos collègues du nombre
du groupe d'études j'aimerais que vous
nous fassiez un point sur votre travaux
en la matière et je pense plus
particulièrement au plan résistant pour
réduire les intrants aux évolutions des
techniques culturales et tout
particulièrement à l'agroesterie
je parle sous votre contrôle monsieur le
directeur l'inrae a démontré qu'une
parcelle agroforestière de 100 hectares
pouvait produire autant de biomasse
qu'une parcelle de 136 hectares où les
arbres et les cultures ont été séparés
pouvez-vous nous apporter des précisions
et votre avis sur cette expérimentation
qui qui semble en tout cas pour mettre
le
le 21 mars l'inrae a présenté ses
travaux sur une agriculture européenne
sans pesticides alors vous l'avez évoqué
en 2050 ma question sera simple 0
pesticide est-il possible en 2050 et
comment
concernant l'engagement de la recherche
privée est-elle à la hauteur des enjeux
et les partenariats publics privés
doivent-ils être renforcés selon vous
merci merci beaucoup
c'est moins que deux minutes bravo
Daniel merci beaucoup pierre loup
ensuite joël Labbé
oui monsieur le directeur
je connais bien le travail que qui a été
fait et je voudrais vous dire quand même
que on reproche souvent à l'inrae d'être
très optimiste
mais en même temps sur la substitution
des molécules chimiques par d'autres
méthodes
mais en même temps
on oublie souvent qu'il faut du temps
qu'il faut du temps et qu'il faut de la
recherche collaborative on le voit bien
pour les néonicotinoïdes voilà il faudra
au moins 6 ans pour mettre véritablement
des solutions en place satisfaisante et
je crois qu'on ne le souligne pas
suffisamment ce qui est catastrophique
c'est supprimer des molécules du jour au
lendemain
au lieu d'avoir une méthode d'approche
moi je veux dire on dirait une molécule
elle va diminuer 10% par an en disant
voilà ça aurait un effet beaucoup plus
positif si on envoie une voiture à 100
km/h dans le mur elle se casse si elle
est il va 10 km/h elle s'en sort bien et
au bout elle sera résistante donc voilà
le constat et je demande à ce que vous
puissiez
dire très clairement le temps qu'il faut
plante résistante de vigne par exemple
il a fallu 20 ans de recherche
et faire croire que en 25 ans on aura
réglé tous les problèmes
ça n'est pas vrai il faut du temps et il
faut de la mutualisation dans les
méthodes sur la betterave encore une
fois on est allé assez vite parce qu'on
avait autour de la table l'ITCF les
groupements de producteurs
les obtenteurs les semenciers et faire
travailler tout le monde là ensemble sur
un objectif précis il faut beaucoup de
moyens beaucoup d'hommes et voilà tout
simplement qu'on puisse rappeler fait 20
impératifs du temps qu'il est nécessaire
pour une bonne évolution merci Pierre
Joël Labé ensuite Henri Cabanel oui
Monsieur le Directeur merci beaucoup de
cette présentation je ça vous surprend
pas je suis vraiment très heureux de
vous entendre et c'est pas par
complaisance votre parole est
scientifique il est important que il est
important qu'on l'entende vous avez dit
que vous avez parlé un peu long vous
auriez pu continuer un peu plus c'est
pas un reproche présenter l'étude
prospective qui vient de sortir par
l'INRA et qui justement démontre comment
arriver à aboutir à cet objectif 2050 je
lis vos conclusions la transition vers
le zéro Phyto nécessite des politiques
publiques cohérentes et articulée alors
notre collègue Pierre loi dit comme on
entend très très souvent ah oui mais il
faut du temps il faudra toujours du
temps quand on ne commence pas et
véritablement la quand l'État l'état des
lieux que vous faites là que nous
connaissons depuis longtemps mais pas
scientifiquement du moins pas à ce
niveau là c'était en février 2015 où
j'ai arraché ma cravate de colère par
rapport au néonicotinoïdes le temps
passe les nœuds nicotinées les choses
sont avancées reculées mais au final les
nicotinoïdes seront remplacés par non
pas par des molécules mais par des
méthodes de culture alors moi je trouve
que c'est extrêmement encourageant de
vous entendre et je ferai une
proposition madame la Présidente pour la
commission de nos affaires économiques
si on pouvait se retrouver en séminaire
pendant deux jours sur ces sujets en
faisant appel à des scientifiques pour
débattre avec eux qu'ils nous présente
l'état de leurs travaux et ça changerait
la face du monde du Sénat je vous
remercie faire une sorte de retraite en
fait voilà bon merci Joël
Henri Cabanel ensuite amalgaquer Henri
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Directeur mais des travaux
déjà que vous faites pour nos
agriculteurs je voudrais m'associer
aussi à ce que vient de dire mon
collègue Daniel Laurent sur les cépages
résistants reste dur et bouquet que vous
avez donc mis sur le secteur pour nous
en faire profiter et je sais que c'est
la seule solution en tout cas en matière
viticole pour pouvoir lutter contre les
intrants il s'agirait simplement que
certaines régions et je vais le dire
soit moins sectaires sur ce sujet là
parce que malheureusement on le constate
moi je voudrais parler donc
effectivement de la de la connaissance
des sols et vous en avez parlé et et le
Costa aujourd'hui est partagé sur le
fait que les pesticides ont détruit au
fil du temps la structure des sols je
voudrais parler d'irrigation parce que
aujourd'hui effectivement
on est dans des alias beaucoup plus
impactant pour les agriculteurs en
termes de sécheresse il est
l'agriculteurs bon ont une solution
assez simple demande de l'eau on sait
pertinemment que l'eau sera riche et que
il sera pratiquement impossible que tous
les agriculteurs puissent bénéficier de
l'eau mais dans un premier temps
avez-vous fait des études sur donc les
les systèmes d'irrigation et leur
efficacité goutte-à-goutte aspersion
goutte à goutte enterré ou en surface et
peut-on lutter effectivement aussi
efficacement contre la sécheresse en
restructurant les sols en matière
organique
et combien de temps ça doit prendre
merci
que j'aimerais évoquer donc est celui de
la gestion durable de l'eau sujet
particulièrement d'actualité en ce
moment les recommandations de l'Institut
concorde avec le des recommandations en
tout cas du plan ou du gouvernement
puisqu'on parle de recyclage d'eau
d'amélioration de la qualité de l'eau
également et trois questions à ce sujet
la première le plan o prévoit une
réduction de la consommation d'eau de
10% dans tous les secteurs d'activités
d'ici 2030 est-ce que cet objectif est
selon vous réalisable quels sont les
points d'attention
particuliers à avoir le plan ne
mentionne pas le contrôle des
prélèvements d'eau
la réalisation de certains forages est
bien sûr réglementée mais les moyens de
contrôle sont faibles ce qui est
dommageable puisque les prélèvements
d'eau sont
accentues généralement le manque d'eau
on a baissé encore le niveau des
rivières et des nappes et des forages
peuvent avoir bien sûr une incidence sur
la qualité de l'eau et en fin dernière
question sur le financement de l'eau
l'agriculture consomme 58% de l'eau la
consommation en eau Pota par les
mélanges représentent 26% de l'industrie
l'énergie représente 16% de la
consommation totale et les ménages
supportent à hauteur de 85% le total des
redevances donc au regard des enjeux à
venir en matière agricoles et
industrielle c'est inéquité entre les
usages et la contribution financière
doit-elle être modifiée et si oui
avez-vous des propositions à soumettre
je vous remercie merci Amel Jean-Claude
Tissot ensuite Bernard but merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Directeur
d'abord permettez-moi de vous remercier
pour
d'agronomique où vous nous avez faite ça
fait quelques rappels ou quelques
informations nouvelles pour certains ce
qui me concernait c'était plutôt des
rappels et quand c'est vous qui
prononcez ce propos
il y a aucune discussion possible
quelquefois nous on essaye de tenir un
peu ce discours mais avec beaucoup plus
de modestie
réelle quant à nos compétences
techniques on a moins d'écoute envers
nos collègues donc c'est bien de temps
en temps et je rejoins de propos de Joël
Labbé si on pouvait avoir quelques fois
des moments plus longs de réflexion sur
ces thèmes là ça serait bien
voilà c'est bien c'est très bien donc
j'ai quelques questions quand même plus
directe Monsieur le Directeur tout
d'abord lors de la récente présentation
du plan o et ma collègue en a parlé
maintenant d'Emmanuel Macron qui a
annoncé que certains ouvrages de
stockage de l'eau pour être accordé à
des agriculteurs sous réserve et je cite
de changement pratique de pratique
significative notamment sur l'usage de
produits phytosanitaires quel regard
portez-vous sur cette annonce et est-ce
que ce nouveau en même temps stockage de
l'eau et réduction des pesticides
étaient abordés dans vos recherches si
oui sur quel critères ensuite pour
revenir sur la récente étude réalisée
par l'inrale sur l'agriculture
européenne c'est autiste était aussi
abordé l'un des points particulièrement
intéressant et que deux des trois
scénarios agroécologiques proposés
permettrait à renforcement de la
souveraineté alimentaire de l'Union
européenne et c'est pourtant un défaut
qui est souvent été mis en avant ici
d'un défaut de l'agroécologie et de
l'agriculture biologique souvent mise en
avant par les défenseurs du modèle
conventionnel du modèle productiviste et
quels sont pour vous les axes importants
à développer pour permettre le
développement conjoint de souveraineté
alimentaire et l'émergence d'un nouveau
modèle agricole plus responsable enfin
une dernière question vous l'avez un peu
abordé la question d'indépendance de la
recherche scientifique particulièrement
sur les sujets alimentaires et agricoles
il est revenu dans les débats ces
derniers temps avec notamment les
questionnements sur la crédibilité de
l'enseest porté par son propre conseil
scientifique on sait également que les
conséquences du conflit qu'on est en
train de en Ukraine une phrase et la
stratégie de la ferme à la fourchette
ont suscité une nouvelle bouclier de
l'industrie agroalimentaire que
pouvez-vous nous dire sur l'indépendance
de la recherche au sein d'une est-ce que
vous avez des inquiétudes sur ce sujet
merci Jean-Claude Bernard buis ensuite
Jean-Marc Boyer merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Directeur
rapidement deux questions avec la
projection de réduction des produits
phytosanitaires et la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre déjà évidente ne pensez-vous
pas que l'on va aller vers des
difficultés de production
est-ce que selon vous les pandage de
pesticides par drone et quelque chose de
fiable et aujourd'hui envisageable
merci pour la concision cher Bernard
Jean-Marc Boyer ensuite pierre Cuypers
oui merci madame la Présidente quand on
raisonne en tonnes de CO2 par habitant
et par an on voit que les États-Unis le
Canada le sont à 15 tonnes le Qatar à 39
tonnes mais là-bas la France elle libère
seulement 5 tonnes de CO2 par an et par
habitant soit 0,8 %
vous nous avez dit au début que
l'agriculture est responsable de 3% des
émissions de CO2 donc si je comprends
bien ces 3% des
0,0,8% donc c'est excessivement faible
donc regarde la protection de la
biodiversité
la biodiversité apporte des services à
l'agriculture c'était votre propos tout
à l'heure mais je pense que les
agriculteurs ont maintenu et
maintiennent la biodiversité l'homme
pensez-vous pas que l'agriculture
apporte un grand service à la
biodiversité c'est ma première question
ma deuxième question concerne la lutte
contre le campagnol terrestre
la limitation de l'utilisation de la
bromatologue depuis maintenant pas mal
d'années
il y a eu des crédits très importants
qui ont été libérés en termes de
recherche non seulement vers l'INRA
aussi vers l'université etc
avez-vous des données sur ces résultats
particuliers sur l'immunocratie
ensuite Anne-Catherine Loisier merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur
plus on cherche plus on trouve
plus on peut s'affaiblir et plus on peut
se mettre en difficulté voilà alors
partant de là quelles sont les
conséquences des néonicotinoïdes par
rapport à la betterave sur le genre
humain
et pourquoi cette brutalité s'il n'y a
pas de conséquence avérée aujourd'hui
réel ne permettrait pas et je rejoins
les propos de pierre-louh à savoir les
délais qui nous sont imposés aujourd'hui
cette cette
force qui est mise pour arrêter toute
une production et qui engendre une et
qui va occasionner une économie qui va
être désastreuse demain notamment en
matière sucre alcool etc etc
je pense que il y a des remarques
pour regarder pour soi
Anne-Catherine Loisier ensuite
Jean-Pierre mauga si madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Directeur alors
d'abord une question qui est un petit
peu une variante de celle de Pierre lot
ou de celle de
en fait on utilise souvent dans nos
instances la formule pas d'interdiction
sans solution je voudrais savoir voilà
comment vous la vous l'appréciez et puis
une question plus précise sur
l'étiquetage et les labels verts dans
l'alimentaire puisque l'exécutif
européen doit présenter des plans pour
une initiative en fait de justification
des allégations environnementales et qui
devrait donc avec l'objectif de
d'imposer des sanctions aux entreprises
qui font des déclarations
environnementales trompeuses ou non
fondée je sais que vous êtes intervenu
sur ces sujets en soulignant en fait la
difficulté d'attribuer une valeur
globale de durabilité à un produit dans
la mesure où ces impacts peuvent être
divers et contradictoires c'est-à-dire
il peut être positif pour la
biodiversité mais négatif en termes
d'impact carbone
et que l'enjeu c'est de faire des
contrôles enfin de pouvoir serait de
pouvoir faire des contrôles tout au long
de la chaîne de valeur
alors quand on connaît l'importance des
produits liés à l'importation en France
en mesure la difficulté donc je dois
savoir quels sont selon vous les les
clés de contrôle quel sera les clés que
vous pourriez proposées et dans votre
réflexion quelle est la part de l'outil
analyse cycle de vie merci
merci beaucoup Anne Catherine
Jean-Pierre mauguet ensuite Daniel merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur des solutions innovantes pour
la gestion de l'eau dans les zones
agricoles ont été développées Enric
Cabanel il a fait allusion tel que les
systèmes d'irrigation
de précision où les capteurs
intelligents pour l'irrigation ou un sol
les recherches en matière d'innovation
technologique à votre avis ces
innovations technologiques si elles
étaient et si elles sont généralisées
peuvent-elles permettre à elle seule de
résoudre cette problématique des
d'épiniers rideau qui qui touchent la
filière agricole quels sont aussi les
techniques agronomiques que vous
recommandez pour réduire la demande à
nous et améliorer l'utilisation de l'eau
dans les zones agricoles
merci Jean-Pierre donc Rémi Cardon et
ensuite le rendu plomb merci madame la
Présidente effectivement je vous poserai
une question assez simple tout à l'heure
j'ai entendu propos de Monsieur loup
effectivement le la question du temps
j'ai entendu aussi d'autres collègues il
y avait une certaine brutalité alors il
me semble qu'il y a eu une la haute
valeur environnementale ce fameux cette
fameuse certification qui date déjà
depuis 2010 donc 13 ans aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pouvez en faire un bilan
de son efficacité pour accompagner vers
justement quelque chose de d'une haute
valeur environnementale en réalité moi
je m'interroge sur le la pertinence de
ce label qui peut pousser le
consommateur dans une
malhonnêteté en termes du sur le contenu
de la de l'alimentation derrière et donc
je pense qu'il y a il est temps aussi de
faire le bilan de ce de cette
certification et donc qu'en pensez-vous
justement à votre titre
sur les évolutions qu'on peut y apporter
merci Rémy Laurent Duplomb pour 2
minutes
merci madame la Présidente je pense que
ça va être difficile de tenir un deux
minutes
d'autant que je passe du stade du
dubitatif au stade de la colère en fait
il me semble que l'Inra a eu trois
stades un premier stade où elle était
spécialisée sur les recherches
techniques en appui aux agriculture et
aux agriculteurs un stade de recherche
quasiment uniquement fondamental et
aujourd'hui on assiste je pense à un
stade de recherche dogmatique je pensais
au contraire que l'INRA pouvait être un
soutien à l'agriculture et aux
agriculteurs et je me rends compte qu'au
fil des messages la totalité du dogme
écologiste poussait à outrance fait la
partie complète de ces recommandations
j'ai deux exemples Monsieur le Directeur
Sandrine Alain chercheur à Grenoble
suite aux annonces du président de la
République nous explique dans toutes les
pages de la presse quotidienne qu'il est
vrai qu'on a plus besoin de stocker de
l'eau et de la retenir pour pouvoir
l'utiliser quand les sols en ont besoin
qu'au contraire il faudrait pousser le
rôle du sol à retenir l'eau car il
serait crucial pour pouvoir s'adapter
sur mon exploitation je viens de des
analyses de sol et je demande à toutes
les exploitations de France et en
particulier certaines à faire la même
chose nous nous retrouvons sur mes
parcelles en gestion d'agriculture
polyculture élevage avec 49 g par kilo
de matière organique donc 28,4 g par
kilo de carbone organique mais seul ne
peuvent pas porter plus de matières
organiques on est quasiment à saturation
et pourtant vous nous expliquez que la
seule solution serait d'avoir de la
matière organique dans les sols mais
seul parce que je suis en terrain
volcanique ou un terrain granitique ne
font pas plus de 15 à 25 cm de
profondeur dessous soit du basalte soit
du granit comment stocker de l'eau dans
des sols alors que ils ne sont pas
suffisamment profonds le deuxième
élément c'est que vous nous dites
deuxième communication zéro pesticides
zéro pesticides en 2050 l'innera di
banco là aussi on nous propose une
multitude de solutions trois scénarios
qui conduisent soit à consommer plus de
fruits et légumes alors que la juste une
seconde s'il te plaît
Laurent pose ta question s'il te plaît
ensuite Daniel salmon oui moi je me
remercie beaucoup monsieur le directeur
pour votre intervention très
intéressante et très pédagogique surtout
moi je vous avais parlé à un moment
donné de la une des pistes était pour
lutter contre les pucerons la
modification aussi du travail
d'organisationnel des agriculteurs qui
allaient devoir analyser beaucoup de
données et y compris chaque année est-ce
que vous avez un travail si un travail
est fait pour la mise en oeuvre
d'applications numériques qui
permettrait d'aider les agriculteurs
dans ce travail d'analyse des données
pour leur permettre de mieux gérer en
temps réel merci
si Viviane Daniel salmon ensuite Franck
Montaud
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le directeur pour votre
brillante exposé qui amène une pensée
vraiment écosystémique et qui nous
permet vraiment d'appréhender toutes les
problématiques de l'agriculture basée
sur beaucoup de chimies
j'aurais aimé que vous puissiez aussi
intervenir sur les métaux la chlore
puisque vous avez bien évoqué les
néonicotinoïdes mais aujourd'hui en
Bretagne en particulier nous avons cette
problématique qui fait que de nombreux
captages sont interdits malgré que l'on
est relevé les seuils et là il s'agit
pas de il s'agit d'un problème de santé
publique ça me semble très important
vous avez évoqué votre budget recherche
qui est le quart de celui de Bayer
pouvez-vous nous faire un point sur la
partie des financements qui sont
les financements publics par rapport au
financement privé parce que on entend
parfois qu'il y a une question
d'indépendance et je pense que il faut
la poser
concernant la vie des sols est-ce que
vous pourriez nous dire quelques
éléments sur tout l'intérêt d'avoir une
polyculture élevage qui permet d'avoir
des des fertilisants organiques par
rapport aux fertilisants on va dire de
synthèse merci
Franck Montauger et pour terminer
Martine Berthet moi que j'ai oublié
quelqu'un merci madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le directeur pour votre
exposé très très intéressant
est-ce que vous avez à l'inrae une
connaissance
exhaustive d'une certaine manière de la
qualité agronomique des sols agricoles
français
et est-ce que vous êtes
vous-même favorable à un inventaire
qui permettrait si vous n'avez pas cette
connaissance voilà d'y parvenir le sol
le sous-sol est un la base de tout
première question deuxième question
rapidement
on entend beaucoup et depuis longtemps
que la production de méthane entériques
est une des causes importantes de
réchauffement climatique alors moi j'ai
un peu de mal à suivre ce type de propos
d'autant plus que voilà quand on cherche
à comprendre on s'aperçoit que que ce
genre de position n'est pas étayé sur
une prise en compte
globale de l'élevage dans son écosystème
j'ai envie de dire et je suis en disant
ça je fais allusion au fonctionnement de
stockage de carbone des prairies etc et
aux conséquences territoriales
économiques et sociales en particulier
si ce n'est environnemental que que peut
avoir la disparition progressive de
l'élevage sur certaines territoires donc
voilà je voudrais savoir si sur ce point
particulier il y a une approche
exhaustive du sujet qui nous permettrait
de pondérer un peu de nuit ainsi un peu
certains propos qui me semblent un petit
peu si ce n'est beaucoup réducteur merci
merci beaucoup Martine Berthet
oui merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
donc deux petites questions la première
lors du syndrome de l'agriculture nous
sommes rendus avec la commission sur
votre stand et nous avons pu voir les
travaux que vous menez concernant
l'alimentation et les les fermentations
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
plus sur vos travaux concernant
l'alimentation l'alimentation protéique
avec
voilà les substituts protéiques est-ce
qu'il y a des travaux que vous mener
là-dessus aussi je pense au sujet
suivant que nous avons fait totalement
autre chose mais justement pour
contrecarrer cela et puis également sur
la question de la biomasse et donc de la
compétition entre les usages qu'elle est
aussi votre regard merci beaucoup
merci
une toute petite
où on sent l'état des recherches sur
l'élevage à savoir la question d'abord
organique la protection des paysages par
rapport à l'alimentation des ruminants
quelle est l'avantage je dirais de la
prairie sur le piège à carbone et
l'apport de l'élevage en matière de
piège à carbone et les recherches sur
l'alimentation animale par rapport à
l'élevage et l'effet des gaz méthane sur
la situation environnementale
voilà petite question
juste une petite question petite
recherche merci beaucoup à chacun
d'entre vous d'avoir joué le jeu
respecter le temps monsieur le directeur
ne vous écoutons pour toutes ces
questions merci je pense que vous allez
devoir décaler votre déjeuner
vu la densité et la qualité des
questions
je vais commencer par le
par les remarques excusez-moi je vais
les prendre au hasard enfin pas non pas
au hasard mais justement dans pas dans
l'ordre j'ai commencé par les remarques
de Monsieur du plomb
mais c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
tant que ça tombe mal il va pas pouvoir
entendre ma réponse
deux points je pense pas que dans que
dans ce que j'ai dit là il y avait du
dogmatisme
et le fait que il ne sera devenu inray
soit passé d'une approche où il y avait
beaucoup de techniques à une approche tu
avais beaucoup de recherches
fondamentales ça fait partie en fait de
l'évolution de pratiquement tous les
organismes de recherche qui a eu à
l'échelle mondiale et et ça fait partie
des missions que le gouvernement nous et
donc l'état nous donne et qui repose sur
le constat que ce qui va ce qui permet
de fonder l'appui technique et de fonder
l'innovation c'est la découverte de
connaissance nouvelle et que donc il
faut faire bouger les frontes
connaissances et ça passe par de la
connaissance alors il a utilisé le mot
fondamental et et nous on parle plutôt
de recherche finalisée c'est-à-dire
produire des connaissances qui peuvent
potentiellement demain
poser sur l'innovation mais aussi peser
sur les politiques publiques c'est ce
lien là
après la remarque sur le fait que nos
chercheurs s'expriment dans la presse
oui on est encore on donne on a on donne
cette liberté aux chercheurs et les
chercheurs ils s'exprime et on essaie de
faire la part des choses entre
l'expression d'un chercheur et
l'expression de l'institution donc voilà
donc je ne commenterai pas davantage
qu'à descendre Rihanna
voilà donc ce point là étant
étant levé
vous avez été plusieurs Monsieur Laurent
monsieur Cabanel
notamment a évoqué les vignes les
cépages résistants en fait ça permet
d'illustrer aussi répondre à l'action de
Monsieur lourd le temps qu'il faut
effectivement vous me disiez monsieur
loi ça fait plus de 20 ans en fait ça
fait beaucoup plus que ça mais c'est pas
je résistant le premier croisement qui a
été fait par
Alain bouquet il a été fait en 1974 avec
une difficulté majeure qui consistait à
aller chercher à réussir à faire un
croisement entre muscadina autantifolia
et Vitis vinifera ce que personne
n'avait réussi à faire à l'échelle
mondiale ça avait été testé en 1919 par
un dénommé Norton qui avait capituler
parce qu'il avait jamais il avait obtenu
des graines mais elles étaient stériles
et donc Alain bouquet il s'est attaqué à
ça et avec
forme de de vocation un peu monacale à y
arriver
et effectivement après on obtient on
obtient les fruits ce qui conduit en
fait à trois points le premier c'est la
recherche est obligé d'explorer des
fronts même si on sait pas que ça va
arriver à quelque chose au bout et
aujourd'hui on est tous contents de dire
on a des cépages de résistants mais si
Alain bouquet à ce temps-là n'avait pas
tapez dans quelque chose ou la
probabilité de réussite était quand même
assez proche du zéro parce que Personne
n'avait fait avant on ne serait pas là
où on est aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui
comme le disait monsieur Cabanel
effectivement il faut y aller tout le
monde est content d'y aller et on va
avoir une révolution en France et à
l'international avec ces systèmes ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
c'est travailler avec les utilisateurs
et parfois travailler malgré le fait que
les utilisateurs ne donnent aucun
signaux intéressant sur les cépages
résistants on a nous on a travaillé
là-dessus pendant longtemps et en fait
on a eu je me souviens de début où je me
suis occupé de ça c'était en 2011 mais
les professionnels ne comprenaient même
pas pourquoi on se posait la question et
c'est en 2016 après une émission de télé
que tout le monde a encore en tête le 6
février 2016 il m'a mémoire est bonne ou
la cabane est tombée sur le chien et
tout le monde dit mais quoi on met des
pesticides sur la vigne bah oui
et donc là des professionnels sont venus
vers nous en disant mais pourquoi il y
en a pas déjà chez nous bah attendez
vous avez vous en avez jamais voulu et
donc on a aujourd'hui ce système là puis
le troisième élément que vous avez
plusieurs à soulever en fait c'est le
temps qu'il faut mais le temps impose
l'anticipation et en fait c'est un peu
ça si on regarde la question des
néonicotinoïdes une des difficultés
qu'on a eues se laver qui avait perdu sa
cravate dans l'événement
en fait voilà mais donc il l'a perdu
mais ce qui avait pu être utilisable
après mais en fait pourquoi en 2015 en
fait toutes les filières n'ont pas
décidé de faire une transition et à
l'époque je m'occupais déjà de betterave
et en fait on avait discuté de ce sujet
là en disant mais non
ça va le faire et donc notre question
elle est pas de de faut pas attendre que
que la stimulation arrive de l'extérieur
et qu'on soit trop tard il faut pas non
plus ouvrir tous les chantiers en même
temps et donc là le point central que
l'on a c'est à quel endroit on arrive à
identifier les sujets qu'il faut
obligatoirement traiter même s'ils ne
sont pas critiques aujourd'hui c'est ce
point là en fait qu'on doit avoir on a
on a discuté de ce sujet là notamment
avec la présidente de Lacta c'est est-ce
qu'il faut pas avoir comme on a un
conseil scientifique sur le on a eu un
conseil scientifique sur le covid avoir
une forme de conseil scientifique de
l'Agriculture de l'Alimentation qui soit
une forme de vigie sur les sujets qu'il
faut qu'il faut ouvrir on a discuté de
ça dans le cadre de la préparation de la
loi qui est en cours de d'élaboration
ministère de la Culture et donc pour moi
c'est ça cet élément là en fait et c'est
pas en fait des formes de négociation en
disant oui mais faut pas aller trop vite
parce que non en fait ces deux tiens
mais c'est quoi les sujets qu'on va qui
vont être devenir critique demain et
c'est pas parce que ça se produira pas
que de fait ça se produira pas et donc
je pense que c'est ça un point important
et ça un corollaire et encore une fois
pour revenir sur cette question de des
interdictions en fait c'est comment on
arrive à avoir un signal politique
suffisamment stable cette question de la
stabilité du signal politique elle est
majeure ça va avec ce que vous aussi
comme question la cohérence des
politiques publiques et si vous avez des
politiques publiques qui pour un
bouddhisme on va de ce côté là l'autre
bout disant va de l'autre côté ça marche
pas et une politique qui change trop
souvent n'est pas pertinente non plus
donc pour moi c'est ce point là qui est
qui est absolument majeur
alors par rapport à ces questions et
pour revenir à la question des des
pesticides
et qui consiste à regarder loin cette
prospective que vous avez mentionné vous
avez été plusieurs à la mentionner et
qu'on a rendu public le 21 mars dernier
effectivement à trois scénarios qui sont
pas des scénarios prescriptifs en fait
c'est des narratifs c'est-à-dire on se
met dans une configuration en disant
une configuration où on a regardé depuis
la production jusqu'à la consommation en
passant par l'organisation des filières
et les scénarios sont très contrastés de
ce point de vue là qui disent mais
est-ce qu'on atteint un état d'équilibre
ce que la différence de pas mal de
scénarios qui ont été faits un scénario
de literie on a voulu avoir nous une
dimension économique et une dimension
environnementale qui a intégré c'est à
dire des scénarios sont chiffrés et ils
sont chez l'homme ce qu'on a des
économistes à bord on a des gens chez
nous qui sont très portés là-dessus qui
portent des grands modèles mondiaux
d'équilibre global et vous pouvez pas
consommer quelque chose que vous n'avez
pas produit ça la définition par contre
quelque chose que vous avez produit vous
pouvez le jeter et donc comment ça
s'organise ces questions là et donc on a
trois scénarios
narratifs dont on a regardé ce qu'ils
avaient ce qu'ils avaient comme incident
sur les fonctionnements des filières
l'organisation locale des dimensions
territoriales et est-ce que à des
évolutions de consommation on pouvait
mettre en face on les combinant alors là
on les a plutôt segmentés mais on peut
aussi les combiner des fronts
d'innovation en matière de levier et
donc le scénario 1 il est à la fois avec
une dimension autour de l'immunité
végétale qui est un champ génétique un
peu émergent et les problématiques de
numérique et digitalisation qui
permettent de d'avoir des efficacités on
retourner autour de l'agriculture de
précision un deuxième bloc qui rejoint
un peu ce que je disais tout à l'heure
sur le microbiote qui consiste à dire
mais en fait on travaille avec qui
s'appelle des holobions nous sommes
aussi des ollaudions savoir c'est un
organisme avec les microbes qui
hébergent et c'est ce que l'on voit en
fait c'est le fruit de interaction de
tout ça et donc en fait la plante si on
la regarde comme étant un olliante
est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça ouvre comme
perspective de recherche entre
maintenant et 2050 notre ambition est
sur ce sujet là d'être les premiers
mondiaux et puis le troisième c'est de
dire je regarde les territoires
agricoles comme étant à la fois des
lieux de régulation et en même temps on
a combiné ça avec un narratif autour de
la consommation localisée donc des
territoires dont vous pouvez retrouver
dans les programmes alimentaires
territoriaux en fait on voit bien que il
y a une forme de relation qui se crée
entre l'endroit où on a produit
l'endroit où on a consommé et des
scénarios sont pas exclusifs l'un
d'autres vous nourrissez vous pouvez
nourrir les territoires français
avec des démarches focalisées mais vous
nourrissez vous nourrirez pas Shanghai
avec ça donc vous aurez toujours besoin
de la coexistence entre des filières
locales et des filières longues et la
coexistence des différents leviers de
protection donc c'est pour ça que c'est
pas des scénarios voilà c'est pour ça
que c'est pas des scénarios
prescriptifs et c'est pas des scénarios
exclusifs mais ça force la réflexion en
disant mais et on voit bien que pour
atteindre des équilibres on pourra pas
faire ce que l'on veut en production si
on réfléchit pas la trajectoire de
consommation et on identifie un élément
qui est critique pour nous c'est si on
est c'est pour ça qu'on a fait si vous
regardez les scénarios il y a des
échelles enfin des fourchettes hautes et
base de production et se dire mais en
fait si on est en dessous de l'échelle
base de production il y a des trucs qui
fonctionnent pas si on est au-dessus et
ben on gagne des degrés de liberté et il
y a un enjeu majeur à la à la dimension
production s'il y a une critique à faire
assez scénarios faut se flageller un peu
une fois de temps en temps en fait c'est
là on a fait le choix de pas intégrer de
façon massive et totalement explicite
l'impact du changement climatique on a
fait une forme de scénario moyen si on
avait en fait un aléatoire un impact du
changement climatique qui est plus
sévère que ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
nos scénarios vont souffrir c'est ça le
j'espère avoir répondu à l'ensemble des
questions que vous avez posées sur ce
sujet là c'est pour nous c'est un
exercice extrêmement important de faire
des scénarios prospectifs et de les
faire en les partage avec des
professionnels c'est à dire on a on a eu
144 experts associés ça a duré pendant
deux ans des experts nationaux issus de
la recherche issus des filières mais
aussi des experts européens et on a fait
on a décliné ces scénarios là dans
quatre territoires
répartis sur l'Europe 1 qui était en
France en viticulture le
Bergerac Duras a enfin lente sur des
filières céréales parce que la Finlande
a une particularité sur ses filières
céréalières un sur les productions
légumières en Roumanie et un sur les
productions céréalières pour finir
longue en Italie donc voilà les
scénarios pour nous en recherche
permettent de projeter et de voir les
grands Gap en fait
et donc en fait à partir de ça la
question c'est est-ce qu'on est n'a des
raisons d'être optimiste ou pas en fait
en fait si vous n'êtes pas un peu
optimiste en recherche vous changez de
métier objectivement parce que en fait
il faut réussir à temps pendant très
très longtemps
quelque chose et il faut réussir à
porter l'enthousiasme des des équipes
des troupes autour de ça et donc en gros
c'est
réussir par des des visions apporter une
ambition et c'est gros la c'est ça qui
mobilise les troupes et c'est aussi ça
qui mobilise en fait les partenariats
alors ça ça rejoint une autre question
que vous avez posée en fait
à la fois la problématique de
l'indépendance et le et le financement
de de la recherche
en fait la recherche elle est elle
effectivement elle doit avoir une
dimension indépendante
ça veut pas dire indépendant coupé du
monde en fait donc je pense que ce qu'on
fait ce matin en fait montre à quel
point on peut être connecté avec avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et puis avec la
représentation nationale que vous êtes
mais la recherche en fait sont son
indépendance elle est
pour nous elle est assurée par son
statut elle assurer par son financement
la question de la part du financement
public il y a une subvention pour charge
de service public qui doit être de 80%
de notre budget si j'ai bonne mémoire et
le reste c'est c'est sur contrat mais
c'est pas la part de contrat avec des
entreprises privées est extrêmement
faible on a beaucoup de contrats à
l'échelle européenne beaucoup d'appels à
projets
au niveau national et la plus
effectivement dans un certain nombre de
cas ces appels à projets sont bilatéraux
c'est-à-dire on est nous recherchent
public avec des entreprises financées
par l'État ce qui n'est pas du tout un
problème d'indépendance en fait en
faisant ça ce que l'on fait c'est qu'au
maximise la vitesse de transfert c'est
ça l'objectif en fait c'est comment on
va plus vite dans le dans le concept et
après l'indépendance de la recherche
elle est assurée par le fait d'avoir en
interne
comme en externe un certain nombre
d'instances qui sont qui deviennent des
garants on a un conseil scientifique
tous nos tous nos dispositifs
partenariaux ou nos grands projets les
peps par exemple pour tous un conseil
scientifique et dans tous les cas on
essaye d'avoir un conseil scientifique
extrêmement ouvert et si possible ouvert
à l'international alors moi je suis un
Européen et un internationaliste
convaincu en particulier en matière de
recherche en fait c'est on n'est pas on
est très fort ensemble et surtout pas
les uns contre les autres et en fait les
le fait d'avoir des grands des grands
chercheurs à l'international présent
dans nos instances est une forme de
garant de notre indépendance et en même
temps une obligation de penser loin et
voilà c'est ça qui a sur notre
indépendance
et après on a des tas de démarches en
interne qui assurent dans des comités
d'éthique et de déontologie qui
permettent de donner des des
guides aux chercheurs pour éviter
d'avoir des
glissements une trop forte dépendance à
des entreprises et on a dans toutes les
configurations une analyse très précise
des conflits d'intérêts voilà donc je
pense que vous pouvez être rassuré sur
cette sur certains dépendance de la
recherche et on s'applique la même chose
dans ce que l'on fait quand on fait de
l'expertise c'est à dire quand on fait
une expertise quelque part ou une
expertise scientifique collective il y a
une déclaration des conflits d'intérêts
qui est obligatoire comme on le fait
quand on va dans des projets européens
dans des démarches européennes donc ce
programme mais vous avez raison ce
Tissot de souligner à quel point il faut
avoir une vigilance permanente là-dessus
je crois donc
sur ces questions là le
Tissot monsieur je regardais monsieur
salon je suis désolé mais voilà cette
question là pour moi elle est elle est
importante alors si je
[Musique]
n'oublie pas des choses voilà vous avez
aussi beaucoup évoqué les questions de
d'irrigation d'eau
c'est un sujet qui est compliqué l'eau
très compliqué
même si effectivement tout à l'heure
Monsieur Laurent disait mais de l'eau il
y en a partout sur avant que nous ne
commencions il y en a partout sur le sur
la terre effectivement le problème c'est
que une grande partie d'entre elles est
salée et
donc comment on gère ça en fait on est
dans un environnement où on a pendant
très longtemps considéré que l'eau était
disponible en quantité illimitée et elle
était indue
fait très longtemps c'est pas si
longtemps que ça en fait qu'on a que
toute la population a un accès continue
à l'eau
dans la région où je vis ça c'est arrivé
dans tous les campagnes qu'en 1960 donc
voilà c'est pas si vieux que ça
donc est-ce qu'on a ce qu'on a qu'est-ce
qui change en fait sur cette question là
en fait ce qui change c'est que sa
disponibilité baisse du fait du
changement climatique et ça va pas
s'arranger alors pourquoi ça baisse du
fait du changement climatique pour les
questions agricoles c'est parce qu'en
fait la répartition elle bouge avec en
particulier des sécheresses estivales
c'est tous les modèles climatiques
convergent vers ça des sécheresse
estivales un peu plus forte et donc
l'eau il y en a moins à ce moment-là
et puis il faut pas oublier que le
premier incidence de l'augmentation est
température c'est une augmentation de
l'évapo-transpiration c'est à dire une
un champ de maïs normalement on était il
va port chaque jour 50 tonnes d'eau par
hectareaux transpiration si vous avez
une augmentation de la température vous
pouvez gratter un millimètre vous passez
à 6 donc ça 60 tonnes et en fait ça ça
augmente la pression sur les besoins et
donc à partir de là c'est quoi les
leviers que l'on a
les leviers c'est un tout petit peu de
jouer sur le fait que le sol peut en
accumuler un peu mais les degrés de
liberté sont assez limités en fait vous
avez plus de chance d'en perdre si le
sol se dégrade en qualité
et donc il y a la dégradation qualité
c'est une baisse de la matière organique
mais c'est aussi en fait une
déstructuration par augmentation des
phénomènes de tassement et auquel cas
vous avez beaucoup moins de stockage
d'eau et en plus l'eau ne s'infiltre pas
donc il y a un petit peu de degré de
liberté là les calculs qui avaient été
faits montrent que si on a augmenté de
quelques points la teneur en matière
organique enfin pas de quelques points
un tout petit peu la matière organique
on pouvait gratter une petite dizaine de
millimètres ce qui fait en gros deux
jours de votre inspiration de maïs c'est
pas beaucoup mais quand vous êtes en
situation critique en fait ça peut être
juste le delta le deuxième c'est de
jouer sur effectivement l'irrigation
donc vous avez été plusieurs à l'évoquer
alors les systèmes d'irrigation que l'on
a en France aujourd'hui
sont des systèmes qui ont été conçus
dans une période où l'eau était
disponible en quantité illimitée donc on
a une irrigation canon
et donc nous on n'a pas fait beaucoup
d'études là-dessus mais il y a beaucoup
d'études disponibles dans la littérature
quand vous iriez au canon donc
[Musique]
de vaporisation de l'eau et donc l'eau
tombe dans des systèmes de basse
pression on basse pression ça
l'inconvénient c'est que ça irrigue
relativement doucement donc c'est des
grands systèmes pour des surfaces
qui sont plus limitées mais par contre
vous avez une perte par vaporisation qui
est un fer à 5%. donc vous avez un grand
Gap
faut pas oublier dans les pertes toutes
les pertes qui sont perdus dans les
réseaux d'adduction
on en parle ces derniers jours à la télé
avec des communes qui font jusqu'à 50%
de perdo en fait c'est ce qui est
critique c'est qu'en fait on commence
par nettoyer l'eau pour la perdre en
fait devrait perdre avant de la nettoyer
mais c'est pas possible et donc cette
vraie que cette question là les
fondamentales en fait vous pouvez faire
exactement le pendant de ça avec les
problématiques alimentaires quand on dit
on n'arrive pas à produire assez pour
pour nous la population faut pas oublier
qu'à 30% de ce qu'on produit qui n'est
jamais consommé qui est perdu l'eau
c'est pareil en fait donc comment on
peut jouer là-dessus et puis le
troisième élément c'est la question de
d'augmenter les logiques de réserve de
réserve utile enfin donc de réserve mise
à disposition des agriculteurs
alors on
moi je personnellement je vis en
Poitou-Charentes même si je travaille à
Paris mais donc ils habitent à 20 km de
Sainte-Soline lieu que maintenant tout
le monde est capable de situer sur une
carte en France il y a un an personne
savait que ça existait même
quelques-uns et en fait
très beau très bel endroit pour faire du
vélo en passant et donc en fait quand
vous regardez on dit c'est des méga
bassines mais si vous regardez donc ça
elles font celles qui est insolites elle
est très grande c'est 600000 m3 mais
contenu de ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure sur les besoins d'irrigation en
fait si vous faites une culture qui
consomme beaucoup par exemple du maïs
sur des années extrêmement sèches et ben
en fait vous avez assez d'eau là pour
régler 300 hectares donc en fait ça
apparaît comme étant quelque chose de
gigantesque pour une surface irridique
et très faible et donc la question à
partir de là elle devient de c'est
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire de ça
qu'est-ce que nous voulons faire de ça
et il y a deux façons de regarder les
choses qui sont pas exclusives l'une de
l'autre le premier c'est de dire mais
est-ce que je dois avoir ces surfaces là
ça s'est volumes là pour avoir une
production
et donc je fais du maïs parce que quand
je mets de l'eau ça beaucoup
ou alors
je sais que je vais avoir des aléas
inter-annuelles très forts et j'utilise
ma bassine pour sécuriser donc dans le
premier cas vous dites je vais répondre
à la tendance moyenne dans le deuxième
cas vous dites je vais couvrir le risque
et en fait cette question là elle est
absolument centrale dans les questions
de changement climatique changement
climatique il a un effet tendentiel mais
il a surtout sur les 20 prochaines
années des variations inter-annuelles
très fortes et donc vous pouvez vous
retrouver dans une configuration ou des
agriculteurs qui vont investir en
collectivement sur des grandes bassines
d'eau ils vont augmenter l'eau
disponible ils peuvent se trouver à
augmenter le nombre de la surface qu'ils
veulent irriguer et bien ça veut dire
qu'on en est extrêmement difficile ils
vont être encore plus en difficulté sur
des surfaces plus grandes et la question
elle est celle-là en fait comment on
gère ce point là ça c'est le premier
point et le deuxième point c'est de dire
mais après tout l'eau on lui donne un
statut privé donc à présent mais l'eau
est un bien commun
est-ce que le fait de réfléchir à l'eau
comme étant un bien commun change la
donne ça rejoint un peu la question que
que vous posiez sur
sur la
la question de réduction des phytos
et dans ce contexte là enfin faire un
ouvrage de stockage d'eau versus réduire
les Phyto en fait ça ce que vous avez
c'est de deux questions qui sont
relatives à des biens communs mais vous
pourriez poser la question de dire mais
après tout si je prélève un bien commun
qu'est-ce que je rends comme autre bien
comment en face effectivement polluer
moins ça peut en faire partie mais vous
pourriez imaginer que dans certains
territoires le bien commun soit le
travail et l'activité économique et donc
si vous dites si vous partez de là
est-ce que quel est le type de culture
que vous irriguez est-ce que vous irez
gagner une culture vous faites des
grains qui sont exportés et auquel cas
vous avez les agriculteurs qui
travaillent et c'est tout à fait
légitime ou alors c'est une activité
économique qui localement va générer
énormément de main d'oeuvre
c'est par exemple du maraîchage ou dans
la région de sainte-solin de la
production de semences qui va générer
semence production de semences qui
génère énormément de d'activités
économiques et de main d'oeuvre
localement et en fait c'est cette
question là qu'il faut se poser et je
pense que cette question des biens
communs en agriculture permet sur des
sujets qui n'étaient contractés parce
qu'il y avait pas de difficulté parce
qu'il y avait peu de contraintes permet
de revisiter des façons de de réfléchir
les choses et surtout ça nous oblige en
fait à aller travailler autrement
collectivement quand je mentionnais tout
à l'heure les terrains les territoires
d'innovation
les territoires d'innovation c'est de
mettre ensemble tous les acteurs y
compris ceux qu'on appelle les
bénéficiaires indirects c'est une
terminologie canadienne en général c'est
les bénéficiaires de rien du tout et
tous ceux qui souffrent et donc comment
en fait on arrive à mettre tout ce petit
monde autour de la table pour construire
un futur qui soit non pas un compromis
mais qui soit un autre scénario et je
pense que cette question est bien commun
avec quelque chose de
d'extrêmement important alors
le temps le temps doit filer et je dois
être trop trop bavard mais
vous avez aussi posé la question de
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
l'épandage pardon est une réponse à ça
mais la pénurie de main d'oeuvre est une
vraie question
vous posez c'est une vraie question
en fait globalement elle est inscrite
dans cette question de de la
transmission qu'on va avoir des
exploitations on a 50% des agriculteurs
qui potentiellement quittent leur
activité dans les 7 à 10 prochaines
années donc libérant des surfaces
considérables est-ce que ça sert à
l'agrandissement des exploitations et
auquel cas on va avoir une augmentation
de la pression sur la main ou est-ce
qu'on arrive à avoir des jeunes qui
arrivent avec des projets qui soient pas
exclusivement des les successeurs de
leurs parents et donc comment on arrive
à donner une vision et donc un futur
optimiste de l'agriculture autour de ça
voilà donc le drone et l'épandage par
drone étant qu'une réponse mais attendez
en disant ça non mais attendez en disant
ça je dis pas que on donne comme seul
perspective aux agriculteurs de se tuer
à la tâche je suis pas du tout pour que
les agriculteurs se tuent à la tâche
c'est pas du tout ça la question c'est
d'avoir un travail décent et un revenu
descend et donc de mobiliser les
techniques au regard de ça et donc la il
faut utiliser toutes les technologies
possibles les drones en font partie mais
il faut pas tomber dans l'autre sens en
disant j'ai une contrainte la
technologie va le résoudre il faut
prendre le problème pour moi tout à fait
dans le sens mais effectivement je suis
d'accord avec vous Madame Présidente
c'est hors de question dire un
agriculteur tu viens alors tu vas mourir
quoi voilà donc
c'est pas ça il faut c'est un métier qui
a qui a du sens et le sens de l'action
ça peut pas être de dire je suis là pour
souffrir
alors qu'est-ce que à cause je n'ai pas
répondu
vous avez madame Martigues posé la
question de la modification des
organisations et du rôle des
applications numériques effectivement
c'est un levier de de la transformation
dans les
dans le cadre de la de la des
discussions qu'on a eu pour la
ploa
une des possibilités une des idées qu'on
a eu qu'on a suggéré c'est de dire les
outils d'aide à la décision c'est une
agression de connaissance pour faire un
outil d'aide à l'addition vous agrégez
toutes les connaissances disponibles et
il faut si vous le faites évoluer et ben
en fait vous prenez les connaissances
sur mesure qu'elles arrivent et elles
sont intégrées et la question c'est
est-ce que on pourrait imaginer des
formes de package d'outils à la décision
qui sont mis à disposition des
agriculteurs au moment où il s'installe
et donc la même façon qu'on fait des
dotations aux jeunes agriculteurs on
fait ce genre de dotation modulo
lependant c'est comment je fais remonter
les informations sur mes pratiques et je
pense que c'est et puis vous pouvez
aller jusqu'au bout en fait ça peut
conduire à faire des formes de jumeaux
numériques de d'exploitation des jumeaux
numériques de ferme mais au moins les
outils d'aide à la décision aujourd'hui
il y en a un certain qui existe mais ils
sont en fait très souvent assez
partielles c'est à dire j'ai un problème
de de champignons sur mes céréales et
j'ai un outil d'aide à l'édition pour
s'envoyer la question c'est comment on
fait des ensembles plus globaux pour
justement intégrer des approches
systémiques là aujourd'hui on a plutôt
fait le contraire donc mais je pense que
là il y a un champ il y a un champ tout
à fait intéressant
et puis et puis après je vais peut-être
m'arrêter là la nori encore faire deux
petits points le peu moins sur le vous
avez mentionné le plusieurs mentionné la
question du S métola chlore
et oui l'inventeur des sols oui voilà
c'était le deuxième point je vais y
arriver c'était le bon c'était mon point
d'après le S métaux la chlore il y a
quand même des choses importantes dans
la ville va se mettre au lac là va se
mettre au laclore a le problème que
c'est un une herbicide qui a été
extrêmement utilisé
parce que parce que pas cher il a généré
ses propres résistances aussi
qu'on a eu on doit maintenir des doses
relativement élevées c'est pour ça que
les réductions ont pas fonctionner il a
beaucoup de résidus et en particulier
dans les sols avec des des strates de
filtration assez limité donc pour ça
qu'on le retrouve beaucoup en Bretagne
en fait sur des sols qui sont issus
d'arène granitique
on a dans le cadre de travaux qu'on fait
pour l'État on a mené un travail
d'évaluation comparatif sur ce produit
là c'est à dire est-ce que si on le
retire il y a des alternatives chimiques
les alternatives en chimiques c'est un
produit sur lequel il y a le
désalternatives chimiques
et donc en fait c'était pas un problème
mais là c'est plus la configuration et
donc en fait la façon dont l'évalue elle
est elle est un peu pervertie par cette
pensée là
en fait il faudrait et on a on a proposé
ça au service de l'État c'est dire mais
plutôt que de même si on est obligé
d'appliquer le règlement mais c'est de
dire plutôt que de réfléchir molécules
par molécules réfléchissons groupe de
molécules par groupe de molécules et
donc par exemple dans le cas du S métola
chlore c'est l'usage de tous les
herbicides à effet racinaires utilisés
sur les cultures cerclées et à ce
moment-là en fait vous vous retrouvez à
dire que la meilleure des options n'est
pas le retrait de molécules c'est
d'avoir un abaissement en le temps que
la transition que d'autres logiques
puissent arriver c'est un abaissement de
des doses homologues alors comment on
peut réduire les deux homologues sans
faire ce que je disais avant l'émergence
de résistance et ben en fait c'est ne
pas désherber la totalité des surfaces
et donc c'est comme c'est des cultures
cerclées c'est obligatoirement des
logiques de désherbinage avec les outils
adaptés ça marche les logiques de
déserminage il y a qu'une culture où
c'est pas possible je la mentionne après
et à ce moment là l'élément d'après
c'est les modalités de contrôle
en fait la difficulté que l'on a
aujourd'hui sur les produits chimiques
c'est qu'on les considère comme un
intrant et pas comme étant quelque chose
qui relève de la santé des plantes si
vous allez chez votre médecin et qui
vous donne une ordonnance pour avoir un
antibiotique vous pouvez pas aller dans
différents pour obtenir 10 boîtes
d'amoxicité
la chlore vous pouvez aller où vous
voulez récupérer les quantités que vous
voulez et en fait il faut qu'on change
notre vision là-dessus
je suis pas du tout pour avoir une
police de tout ça en fait mais c'est
comment on arrive à l'encadrer et
et encore une fois je suis pas favorable
à faire la police là dessus je pense que
c'est vraiment un changement d'état
d'esprit là-dessus et ça passera parce
qu'il y aura des options mais le retrait
de molécules aujourd'hui en fait pour
certains moments il faut le faire mais
pour d'autres parce que l'impact est
juste beaucoup trop fort et puis il faut
donner un signal mais pour d'autres en
fait c'est sans doute pas la meilleure
des options et puis après sur la vie des
sols et ça sera mon dernier point on a
effectivement
non mais attendez je vais y arriver les
sols et l'élevage pour moi c'est la même
chose non non en fait on a on a
aujourd'hui des cartes des sols donc on
a on est le ce qui hébergeons
la base sur la sur les sols en France
donc il y a on a un groupement d'intérêt
scientifiques sur les sols qui s'appelle
gissol
qui héberge qui regroupe en fait toutes
les données d'analyse qui sont faites
sur l'ensemble des soldes de France donc
si vous allez si vous voulez récupérer
des superbes cartes vous allez j'y sol
et vous pouvez récupérer des
les cartes d'état des sols en France
avec les teneurs en matière organique
les réserves utiles les teneurs de tous
les composés que vous souhaitez tout est
disponible et chaque fois qu'un
agriculteur fait une analyse de sol en
fait la donnée peut remonter donc on a
un système qui s'enrichit on a aussi
quelque chose qui est fait qui se
rajoute à ça c'est l'analyse des
micro-organismes dans les sols mesuré
par la quantification de l'ADN bactérien
qui a dans les sols donc on quantifie
alors c'est beaucoup moins dense comme
carte plus un peu plus extrapolation
mais on quantifie les quantités d'ADN
disponibles donc ça c'est aussi une
cartographie qui est qui est faite et
donc
dans dans ces sols effectivement
l'élevage joue un rôle considérable
pour deux par deux mécanismes différents
d'abord si vous faites de lait alors
quand on parle l'élevage en fait on
parle toujours élevage herbivore
effectivement les les pores et les
volailles n'ont pratiquement aucun effet
là-dessus qui mange des grains mais sur
l'élevage herbivores qui est quand même
les prairies en France c'est 9 millions
d'hectares et si vous rajoutez à ça 1,5
millions d'hectares de maïs à peu près
10 millions d'hectares qui sont
consommés par des herbivores
les prairies en tant que tel par leur le
fait que ce soit des structures pérennes
elles vont augmenter les les
restitutions de carbone au sol et pour
il faut savoir que pour maintenir dans
les sols français le carbone là où il
est il faut restituer en moyenne de nos
climats 1,9 tonnes de carbone par
hectare et par an sinon la
microorganismes du sol ils passent leur
temps à manger du carbone donc les
prairies font ça très bien et si vous
augmentez vous avez de l'élevage vous
avez plus de prairies
vous pouvez aussi faire de l'élevage
qu'avec l'élevage de ruminants qu'avec
du maïs auquel cas ça le fait pas loin
donc ils ont il a ils ont un rôle clé
là-dessus et donc un lien des enjeux
majeurs qui est la gestion de ces
prairies là si on va avoir plus de
prairie il y a un enjeu à l'augmentation
de leurs production parce que sinon
l'arbitrage se fait et il y a un enjeu
absolument considérable à la composition
fleuristique des prairies et donc des
prairies de graminées exclusive c'est
pas une bonne chose des prairies
d'associations graminées légumineuses
c'est nettement mieux et ça fait le lien
avec une autre question que vous avez
posé sur les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre
pourquoi on en veut au méthane des
vaches
la vache émet du méthane parce que elle
a un rumen qui lui permet de dégrader de
la cellulose ce que nous nous sommes
totalement incapables de faire et le
mécanisme de
dégradation de la cellulose conduit à
l'émission de métal
il y a des travaux aujourd'hui pour
chercher des produits des additifs
alimentaires et un additif alimentaire
qui est sur le marché qui est le bois
vert
boav qui est en fait la molécule c'est
le 3 nop qui en fait va modifier un tout
petit peu l'équilibre des bactéries du
rhumaine et donc faire baisser la
population de bactéries méthanogènes
pourquoi en fait il y a une pression qui
est mise est-ce que est-ce que c'est
pertinent de mettre une pression sur le
méthane des vaches la réponse elle est
si vous regardez l'échelle globale la
réponse est non parce qu'en fait on
n'aimait pas plus de méthane des
ruminants aujourd'hui qu'on en mettait
il y a 12 ans or 12 ans c'est la durée
de vie du méthane dans l'air vous pouvez
dire après tout on augmente pas la
pression par contre dans l'autre sens il
voulait une politique publique où vous
avez un effondrement rapide de vos
émissions gaz à effet de serre vous
devez taper sur ce qui a un effet majeur
donc il y a un pouvoir de réchauffement
global qui est de 30 et un temps de
résidence qui est court de façon c'est
assez fou mais donc ça c'est une action
mais les ruminants ils ont ils sont pas
totalement dédoués quand même dans
l'histoire parce qu'en fait en moyenne
si vous faites du lait de la viande vous
avez besoin de 4 à 5 kg de protéines
végétales pour faire 1 kg de protéines
animales et donc en fait c'est le poids
en termes d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre des ruminants il est beaucoup plus
par le protoxyde d'azote qui est lié à
la culture des végétaux qui est devant
[Musique]
mais surtout le couplage production
animale production végétale et avec la
particularité que l'on a dans les
territoires comme la France c'est qu'en
fait on les a géographiquement séparés
donc les élevages sont spécialisés en
certaines régions et les grandes
cultures sont spécialisées et donc la
question elle est est-ce que quels sont
les marges de manœuvre qu'on a sur la
des spécialisation des territoires mais
pour des spécialiser un territoire vous
pouvez éventuellement des spécialiser
les exploitations mais ça suppose qu'il
y a une usine associée et en fait c'est
pour ça que
ça va je vais m'arrêter là c'est pour ça
que dans toutes les réflexions que l'on
a on prend l'ensemble du bloc depuis la
production jusqu'à la consommation avec
cette étape intermédiaires voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire et je vous prie de
m'excuser d'avoir été un peu long merci
beaucoup Monsieur le Directeur merci
infiniment pour cette audition qui
laisse évidemment beaucoup de curiosités
aux uns et aux autres à la fois d'aller
sur vos travaux peut-être d'aller plus
loin dans le voilà dans nous-même la
recherche
euh moi j'ai bien bien entendu
ce que vous nous avez expliqué dans ces
deux heures sur
la recherche globale que vous faites sur
les écosystèmes entier qui me paraît
vraiment être intéressant après les uns
et les autres on a des différences et
des appréciations différentes je pense
que travailler en commun filière
innovation recherche
et puis parler de bien public il y a une
petite marche peut-être qui fait que
voilà les uns et les autres sont plus ou
moins plus ou moins d'accord mais je
crois qu'on est on va dans le même sens
en tout cas merci beaucoup pour cette
pour cette audition passionnante merci
merci beaucoup
et nous ne regretterons pas monsieur
mondial même si on sera très ravi de le
voir voilà merci je demande à mes
collègues de bien rester le temps de la
petite pause voilà pour la suite de
l'ordre du jour merci